l'épisode d'aujourd'hui est présenté par
fs a eu l'aval la faculté des sciences
de l'administration de l'université
laval université qu'on a tous les deux
fréquenté qu'on a adoré moi je répèterai
l'expérience j'y retournerais demain
matin vraiment une belle université
située à québec mais qui ont également
une plateforme en ligne
incroyable et la faculté des sciences
d'administration plus de 40 programmes
de bacs de maîtrise aussi des
microprogrammes des certificats des
moyens des programmes pour tous les
besoins pour tous les goûts si patate
que vous pensez peut-être retourner aux
études
dans ces temps de pandémie pour aller
chercher des nouveaux ces temps
incertains aller chercher des nouveaux
styles une des nouvelles choses
peut-être vous servez dans votre vie
professionnelle qui va peut-être vous
vous permettre d'aller chercher une
promotion peut-être ou juste avoir des
outils pour votre business à vous ou peu
importe vos besoins il ya vraiment un
programme sans doute sur mesure pour
vous par exemple que j'ai regardé leur
programme en fait même moi
personnellement j'ai quand même si on
n'est que jeu comme tombe un peu dans le
monde de l'entrepreneuriat malgré moi
avec un parcours en littérature donc qui
est vraiment des outils que je pourrais
aller chercher l'appui je regarde
honnêtement pour voir si une possibilité
pour moi en fait puis duras depuis le
début du premier confinement en fait il
ya beaucoup d'universités qui sont
réorientés pour essayer d'offrir des
classes en ligne mais en prenant la
formule présentiel et en essayant de
transformer ça en ligne des fois ça fait
des cours qui sont un peu laborieux mais
fs à laval le ça fait plus de 25 ans qui
offre des cours en ligne donc les cours
sont déjà montées c'est déjà fait pour
être interactif pour être le fun à faire
donc durant ce confinement qui vont
encore su continuer durant un certain
temps en fait une bonne option en garde
et donc si vous voulez avoir plus
d'informations vous informer sur les
programmes qui sont offerts on va mettre
le lien pour aller voir ce dans la
description du podcast donc on vous
invite à aller vous informer et merci
beaucoup pour ce partenaire pour ce
partenariat la puis pas besoin d'être
basée à québec en plus c'est ce qu'il me
fait face et court le peu importe où au
québec ou même à l'extérieur parce que
la plateforme en ligne est juste
incroyable est parfaite
yes merci le podcast aujourd'hui est
également présentée par roche lag qui
continue en fait leur partenariat avec
le sans fil
le centre un peu podcast pour le mois de
janvier
ashland c'est une micro brasseries
québécoises qui se distinguent par leur
produit d'une excessivement grande
qualité jeudi excessif parce que nous
cela bien qu'on boit en fait seul sans
filtre podcast pissou sladek en bois
qu'un convoi donjons et dragons
c'est aussi la bière qu'on boit quand on
joue à donjons dragons
ça faisait quelques bonnes effectivement
parce que nos personnages sont assez
comme on dit qui est qui sur leur bière
c'était essentiellement d'ingrédients
québécois
pensez simplement à la bière miettes qui
est une guerre blanche fait de pain
récupérer des boulangeries beta pain
donc économie 360 ont réduit le
gaspillage alimentaire tous ceux en
faisant des produits d'une grande
qualité
les bières c'est évidemment pas la seule
chose que schlague offre n'est ce pas on
a les jeans ici que vous pouvez trouver
où partout vous achetez du ginger ale
sécu le jean dans des lions le djinn
hibiscus et font aussi dit jean tonique
des jeux en canette jean panique est
vraiment ils ont un super bon choix des
teintes aux knicks dans les bières dont
le des planches c'est une bière à la
mangue sur des routes toutes sortes de
bières pour tous les goûts des goûts
pardon des bons produits jardin roche
lag
merci la gagne de flag pour ce
partenariat en continu puis on vous aime
pas on aime aux produits puis le
packaging et six chiens chan précis
toujours le toujours important de
préciser quand quelque chose est bien
fait insel merci la gamme michelin hier
une production du studio sf bio sans
filtre le podcast on parle de ce qu'on
veut avec nos invités dati site je suis
presque en temps avec moi de me plante
abonnez vous à notre page p tu es la
gagne c'est là que ça se passe on fait
un encore moins de filtres après tout
les podcasts parce qu'on dise que d'un
petit peu deux mois et nicole de comment
ça s'est passé notre interprétation des
conversations puis c'est la meilleure
façon nous encourager pour vrai puis on
vous aime gagner pétrole quand vous êtes
même bout et qui nous écoutent et qui
sont pas sûrs petur même chez vous
qu'ils entendent présenter cette semaine
d'hommes seuls sans filtre cette semaine
on reçoit monsieur guillaume dulude de
son nouveau livre je suis un chercheur
d'or les mécanismes de la communication
et des relations humaines
c'est un genre de experts ce mythe est à
dans l'art de communiquer ces dynamiques
le des relations puis la communication
humaine c'est vraiment fascinant
peut-être dû à tout le monde en parle de
quelques semaines c'est vraiment pas
intéressant des cadets c'est aussi
quelqu'un je te maquis qui a passé sa
vie à s'intéresser à ce on a aussi parlé
de on est toujours en commun avec
guillaume c'est un passé d'athlète de
natation effet les compétitions comme
nous des quand même ok les bras c'est
vraiment fixé mais quand on ne parlait
depuis les liens qui a fait rentrer la
natation le travail d'améliorer la
technique ça se parle up
comment qu'on peut appliquer ce cd
baissent de rigueur loeb c'est espèce de
désir de s'améliorer dans la
communication dans nos relations
humaines
c'était super intéressant on a parlé
aussi du conseil des consentements qu'on
a abordé
on a abordé vraiment plein plein de
sujets spa passionnant l'homme le plus
intéressant du québec guillaume dulout
vraiment puis puisque ces enfants
participer aux conversations laisser des
commentaires mettez les top up
abonnez vous à nos chaînes les séries
thing et 5 étoiles sur l'application
podcast vous savez allaitement rendu la
fonction rendu le
vous savez quoi former mais faites-le
prenez action ce qu'on fait un call to
action prenait action audace et ça va me
donner un grand coup de main mais
vraiment surtout profiter la
conversation fait que mon podcast
houllier
[Musique]
il se lie merci d'être là c'est vraiment
apprécié on peut partir dans toutes les
directions et a été un temps suggérée
beaucoup depuis le début de podcasts
vraiment attendu si longtemps mais le
tout voilà je suis là mais fait qu tant
mieux et qu'il ya beaucoup de monde
j'imagine que la communication j'ai
quelque chose que les gens désirent
approfondir davantage peut-être que tout
le monde communique semble meiway
débutant au début en fait de tous âges
écouté hier taton lancement de ton
nouveau livre puis tu commence en disant
que l'idée d'être intéressé à la
communication est venue par la natation
fait quoi nous on est deux nageurs deux
anciens agents que moi j'ai nagé de toi
t'as quel âge
cissé fois il inscrit 37 puis maintenant
jusqu'à 15
jusqu'en 2008 les smp devedjian break
est fait quand on sait chevauchent
urgent que moi aussi je t'ai la highway
moi je n'aurais pour l'université laval
ok ouais j'ai nagé tout mon université à
l'universel avale toutes mes cinq
universitaires de niveau canadien
50 cent livres 212 500 du cinsault
toussaint - s'écrouler mais p moi je
n'avais aucune idée de ce fait le yar je
tombe un peu dans dans toutes et toutes
les choses que ce faible toupie son
lancement tu lances l'image clair en
montrant et vidéos de macao faire pour
essayer d'illustrer lacombe la
communication ainsi depuis le corrige
moi mais parce que moi ça l'a tellement
raisonné que je vais t'expliquer
pourquoi après fait explique en montrant
une vidéo marco faire puisque ce qui
permet aux nageurs de haut niveau d'un
an j'ai rapidement versus quelqu'un qui
se noie
c'est la compréhension que l'eau il faut
que ce stade il faut que l'on arrête de
bouger puis que le contact clos fait
avec tellement est ce qu'on appelle un
appui communément appelée appuyons-nous
on n'a pas besoin de s'expliquer qu'est
ce qu'un appui mais quelqu'un qui sait
pas si c'est justement le contact
entamant lots en avant pis que c'est ça
qui crée le momentum vers la main sauf
que ce concept là si tu l'as jamais
expérimenté tu peux pas le comprendre
puis moi il m'est arrivé en est une
situation est-ce que moi ma force celtic
fouillent sulu fait que la boîte est un
papillon pour ceux qui nous écoutent
sous l'eau avant de commencer à manger
et emmenés au rouge et or le collège
rouget ramène tout les nageurs de son
groupe dans un local plein dit ph
je suis pas capable d'expliquer comme du
monde à certaines personnes si pelé
voulait pas pointer personne me dit je
peux regarder explique homme du monde
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui fait est bon
o'keefe le solo puis le mois de
d'arriver de fer sur le sache
faut que tu comprennes comprends pas
c'est tellement abstrait puis qu'elle
est là quel est le lien que tu fais
finalement avec ce pour ceux qui nous
écoutent le plus de lancers la parole
finalement après avoir trop parlé devant
toi mais quel est le lien qui suit avec
ça en fait avec la communication la
façon dont tu interagit avec les
éléments de l'univers vaut créer quelque
chose une troisième partie un troisième
effet qui nie dans une matière ni dans
une autre c'est à dire que par exemple
l'appui la grippe que tout sous l'eau
c'est dur à décrire mais à force de
travail et a conscience tic
kinesthésique à force de travail et de
t'entraîner de souffrir dans l'eau ton
cerveau se défend en trouvant une façon
de communiquer avec l'univers si tu le
mets ton et et quand il comprend
certaines règles il fait apparaître
quelque chose qui n'est pas ni dans ta
main ni dans l'eau mais ça existe pour
vrai et je peux mesurer l'impact de son
camp
par exemple manger plus vite la vitesse
souhaitée le déplacement donc ça veut
dire que il ya une façon dont les
humains peuvent interagir avec l'univers
qui quand tu ne maîtrises pas la
technique c'est comme si rien tout est
flou toutim ou d'une noix dans l'eau ça
sert à rien mais à force de travail de
repousser la conscience technique tu
crées des nouvelles dimensions de ce qui
peut arriver autour de toi pour moi ça
c'est de la communication c'est à dire
une forme d'interaction qui crie quelque
chose qui est absent de la conscience
pourtant et pourtant que ça deviez
présent pis ça décor d impact concret
observa mesurables dans la vie sobre
donc pour moi la natation c'est soit
c'est la magie que ta technique
à force de travail et va faire
apparaître des choses et savoir des
conséquences majeures concrètes ça va
repousser les limites ça va devenir
permanent dans toi parce que quand tu
sais c'est quoi le feeling de l'eau
quand il sait quoi la grippe en avant tu
peux plus effacer sa dette atteint
facture pour toujours pour toujours il
ya plus deux or j'ai oublié c'est quoi
les photos d apprendre à nager c'est sûr
noir plus jamais c'est ça la conscience
c'est comme un peu l'univers ça prend
toujours de l'expansion sa soirée tracts
pour ces faits comme ça donc l'univers
est fait comme ça l'esprit humain fait
comme seul en humaines et fait comme sur
la conscience est fait comme ça et ce
qu'ils font c'est un humain c'est fait
pour prendre de l'expansion de cette
façon là et c'est ce qui fait en sorte
que tu peux tu peux changer des choses
pour améliorer le monde autant qu est un
milliard et one est fait pour moi
la communication c'est ce pour quoi ça
sert à quoi qu'on met tant que je suis
ici pour qu'on sport ça s'arrête
toujours bien écrits de conversation qui
n'existait pas avant
qu'est ce que ça va faire sa musique en
a d'autres qui vont écouter celui lui
tout le monde doit se regarder tout le
monde l'écouté des enfants puis les gens
vont être transformées suite à des
conversations qui c'est sûr qu'ils
seront pas transformés à 100%
un petit peu des petites choses qui vont
apparaître mais l'accumulation ces
petites choses la faim en sorte que ton
regard sur le monde change tu vois des
choses que tu voyais pas un vain et
cette vision là que tu le vois avec ta
main ou que tu vois que ton car autour
acté yeux c'est le même impact pour moi
bref comme la natation à force de
répétition à force de travail et on
pourrait me lyon-caen votre
communication en français ce qui dit oui
puis non seulement amélioré mais tu peux
sentir des affaires nouvelles du peut
cacher des affaires comme ceux d'une
personne jeu ça regarde comment respire
ça va loin là autant l'option du
magazine mais ce n'est dans l'eau ça
avance pas ce qui est vendu lotus comme
n'importe quel bon d'argent mais ça met
dans l'eau ça avance complément un homme
en jean c'est la même chose avec la
communication tue souvent les gens
pensent que ce que mon affaire
ésotérique de lire dans l'esprit il ya
comme un spaghetti met autour de tous
bords pour sa part en toute logique la
médaille de la technique c'est 100%
technique qui s'entraînent 100% pour ça
puis à force de pratiquer suffit d'aimer
ce come to grid dans l'au delà même
groupe
dans une communication qui comprend des
affaires est vêtu contre exactement ce
que la personne veut dire sans même les
affaires qu'elle a pas conscience
elle-même
tu sens que tu en voilà tu sais tu peux
même collé des choses six mois d'av ans
juste parce que tous à son mouvement son
move un peu puis ça c'est juste une
forme d'empathie qui le résultat de ce
passionné parle pour lui-même puis le
comprendre sur 513 donc toi dans le fond
dans ton parcours de développer cette
technique les 7 or le décoder la
communication qu'elle soit verbale ou
non verbale fond we fuck me kim et tong
ont fait pose vite avait analysé mettant
ce que tu connais de moi de ce que te
connaître parce que du go avec les cinq
minutes qu'on se connaît maintenant je
peux pas faire ça jamais jamais jamais
faut jamais face à fulham effacer
l'image
je ne sais pas ça c'est que même si je
le dis vous allez faire comme moi qui
s'arrangera pour sa vraie comme du barça
avec comme c'est justement dans ce sens
mais tu fais quand même
consciemment ou inconsciemment quatre
ans contre quelqu'un il ya une analyse
qui fait parce que tout parce que toi tu
a entraîné ses muscles
bon ok les jeunes certains patients sont
terrorisés à l'idée de me parler parce
qu'ils ont peur que je lise quelque
chose me suis juste furieux c'est ça il
y en a que je sais juste qu'il y en a
d'autres
ils sont terrorisés mais ça dépend
comment on définit le mot analyse
ok c'est souvent l'analyse c'est très
rationnelle de ses traits j'observe et
je décris quelque chose mais c'est pas
comme ça dans vraie vie dans vraie vie
tu vis comme un peu mes temps quand vous
mangez
je voudrais qu'on peut bien décrire
chaque traction n'est pas un tournage tu
manges est une lente plongée pense peau
tu peux penser une coupe d'affaires un
peu tu peux pas ça tongs et gardez pas
tardé à faire consommer tués dans un
mouvement tu le fais tu es pas
l'extérieur de l'eau en train d'écrire
une analyse d'un large sac ces deux jobs
c'est quand tu es dans l'eau tu es dans
l'hôtel jouit le sport tu sens des
affaires mais tu rationalise pour soi
comme le jeudi je peux vraiment être
décret d affamer je suis pas occupé à
faire ce jeu 3is un moment je le veux ce
moment là pour moi afin que je me
détache pas de sushi pleinement impliqué
là dedans puis je sens des affaires mais
je vois pas décodé ou raisonnée ou
analyser toute amitié skills de
communication ce qui fait que tu es
peut-être plus à l'aise c'est peut-être
plus facile face et pour toi de créer un
lien avec quelqu'un
ouais mais tu seras pas nécessairement
capables de tout expliquer
rationnellement commun d'argent
cependant c'est en tout cas capable
d'expliquer chacun de ses mouvements
pourquoi ça fait avancer plus vite parce
que je crois est ce que je calcule non
parce qu'il ya deux choses c'est que
j'ai lancé je le vis nous apprend fait
été capable de le verbaliser
oui je capable de l'expliquer puisque a
pas de montre aux autres comment le
faire à leur façon
bakchich capable de tout expliquer très
rationnel mais si j'ai à le montrer si
j'ai pas le montrer tu vis le truc tu
m'avais le sport roi tu le moment ces
facteurs comme deux dimensions
huawei qui est ce que c est ce que c'est
des copies dangereux c'est sûr
aucun proche du coach maintenant le
coach athlètes dans ce laps choc les
deux animaux puis une fructueuse ce
déclic leur mettons par rapport à l'an
tation picto fait le lien qu'elle a été
quelqu'un qui ont été les étapes pour
toi après ce qu'est ce que qu'est ce que
tu as fait maintenant ta vie de dire
qu'il leur faudrait chercher ces
informations-là commenge comment je m'y
prends puis vers oussama merde j'ai
tellement content de parler d'autres
sources basséen et compte en seconde
année de natation mais non mais c'est
quoi ces ex tellement le fun pouvoir
enfin parler des gens qui comprennent ça
c'est le principe ultime ktc moi mais
c'est pour ça que sert tellement
raisonnée c'est que moi j'étais coach
aussi après ouais puis un ange heures
qui le comprend pas il comme pas deux
façons de s'y rendre et puis tu puisses
et locke était capable de déceler tout
de suite un joueur qui a vraiment du
potentiel versus ont un joueur qui en a
moins de faire lui quand j'essaye de
faire comprendre concepts ont notamment
l'appui de cet homme un mot faire sortir
un jeune de l'eau dire pas moi c'est moi
c'est ça qu'il faut que tu ressens dans
l'eau aussi comprends pas qu'on prend
parti mais quatre explique un concept
qui est quand même abstrait à quelqu'un
qu'il comprend ouais ben là c'est comme
si quelque chose d'autre c'est une très
belle chose d'autre qu'est-ce-qui qu'est
ce qui était la leur qu'est-ce qui était
le chemin
mais premièrement j'ai j'ai réalisé que
la technique si je suis quand j'ai
commencé là j'ai commencé un ange à cet
art et moi je suis pas jeune en tout
l'espace bon n'a absolument rien manquer
dans les choix c'est le cas des bons
dangereux même si je pense à tous les
sports
puis je me souviens je commence à manger
depuis je t'ai pas bon c'est bien
évidemment puis les petites filles mais
clan chuté comme ça confiait t pas
comment une fille plus petites plus
jeunes me clanche le préfet du fleix du
papillon tchèque sous l'eau à des pannes
6 à ce propos ce qu'on ne veut pas quoi
sa vie doute comment pourquoi je fais la
même affaire qu'elle je prends ma pts
est objectivement plus fort qu'elle loin
dire à quel point c'est bon alors je
plus vite pourquoi mais c'est ça le
mystère du truc
ouais c'était comme je me suis tellement
fâché je regarde et se loge des
commentaires je comprends pas je fais la
même affaire
puis c'est plus allongée au coup de
crosse mais ça n'a juste plus vite s'il
y croit elle que j'ai comme pas accepté
jeudi comme ab crise non non non non aux
pauvres que je trouve ça plus que les
autres gardent tous et le groupe des
enfants la méthode au lecteur comme
celle là tu es comme c'est un autre
niveau c'est les bateaux le thé comme
nous c'est impossible
plus tu dis c'est des humains la fac
c'est sûr que c'est possible on a les
mêmes soucis
c'est sûrement aller même si j'ai
souvent maintenant quand je jouais au
hockey aussi
puis je me disais mais ton on était on
se faisait clencher on perd 4 après une
période plus je me disais ah oui ça
regarde mal mais nous aussi on est
capable de faire qu'attendu dans l'autre
sens parce qu'on est des humains aussi
déjà visibles moi je comprenais pas
comment est ce que d'autres peuvent être
tellement meilleurs que nous autres
qu'on pourrait faire clencher on est des
humains
si on a les mêmes soucis ben c'est sûr
c'est ici toute la notion de yule
potentiel à l'intérieur des jambes sur
600 sans oreiller ou le potentiel parce
que des humains ne sont pas capables de
fond de contacter leurs potentiels vont
être extrêmement l'un va le malheureux
puis ils vont avoir des compensations
typique dont tête on pourra parler
tantôt mai
puis on est brève dans une période comme
ceux actuellement socialement ccd jeu
les gens souffrent et sont son pack a
pas vraiment de l'utiliser qui sont à
100%
bref pour revenir à comment comment j'ai
fait ça mais là je me suis dit mais moi
je vais apprendre je vais apprendre à
manger d'abord je veux apprendre plus de
demander au coach mais comme comment
pourquoi ils en jettent comme sap lui
donne une réponse floue et ont même si
l'entraînement jeux nominés pour vrai le
qu'est ce qui fait dix mois les jugera
le faire
c'est juste ma vie je le fais mesurer là
c'est mon petit ma main je le fais à
fait juste leur donner la recette se
fait plus haut comme moi ça marche pas
de même ça marche pas mais moi je le
fais ne sont qu'un moyen sa gamme prend
du temps pourquoi tu me ramènes que
c'est quoi le championnat fait un
mouvement qui s'est écarté 6 2
c'est un cobra cinkassé sommet en temps
réel de peu le temps de compléter toute
la subtilité des mouvements faut qu'ils
fassent des milliers dans ce sens c'est
que vu de l'extérieur ça a l'air simple
mais c'est imperceptible comme
l'interaction avec l'océan soucier de la
dépasser la comprend puis celle au cma
donné à force d'énergie mamic bang des
filets c'est le fameux philly le
distingue de la panne géante le puits là
le super ça va ça vient
le lacet littéralement pouvoir magique
quand tu pointes et première grippe pour
cela tube sa glisse tu fais ok gelé le
lendemain à 7 jours mais quand même un
place toumo catch c'est comme c'est très
volatile du fait que je me suis dit moi
je veux être un expert de technique
c'est de la technique que je fais partie
puis je me souviens que mon coach
m'avait filmer sous l'eau faisant un
petit crochet que mon coach me corriger
wanetam un plus dans le semblent jetés
comme au québec
penses tu vraiment déplacé soit d'un
pouce que geof là il dit ben ouais je
regarde jouer à la fin tu vas voir je
n'aurais pas plus vite loin mais ça
marche
il ya comme une frustration quand il va
apprendre quelque chose de complexe
n'est pas capable de le faire tout de
suite parce que c'est pas il faut que
crée ton interaction avec les éléments
c'est ce que j'ai trouvé tellement
merveilleux puis de la vraie drogue avec
la natation akiyo sopi après son mât
mais quand tu deviens meilleur tu dis
aimez moi je veux montre je le montrais
quelqu'un pas je le sais qu est-ce qui
veut le lui le petit lob l'idée que moi
je mange pas vrai je regardais ce cadeau
le point mois
moi je le pitch à tout le monde et plus
je me dis ok le tabou tiens un autre
problème c'est la commémoration à le
transmettre
lorsqu'un moi qui me suis je dit des
mots silver élections dit parce que des
mots on comprend rationnellement des
affamés pour que l'accord vivre quelque
chose de notre guide pour transformer
des mots en résulta observable c'est un
autre game complètement
je veux qu'ils me le faut je transforme
en langage faut je parle un langage
corporel qu'il faut je parle le corps de
cet athlète pas parce qu'il fait comme
ça puis je puisse vraiment la force de
kochi c'est comme si j'habitais d'un
corps d'un athlète
puis je me disais lui soient assez
faibles sur melty ya un processus de
sensations la fac je sais que lui il se
défoule sur tel à faire tout ce qui est
pendu le fait que tu développes une
empathie kinesthésique fac c'est comme
ça que j'ai bâti ma passion sur de la
communication pas je me suis dit comment
je vais parler le langage que lui a
besoin pour allumer les bonnes prises de
conscience pour faire allumer un essai
petit et je mangeais panier de quoi y
assister qu est ce qu elle l algorithme
que je dois placer dans son corps dans
sa tête dans ses sentiments pour qu'une
petite magie à arrive ça a été sur la
communication pour moi le début a à
quatre niveaux en plus parce que c'est
comment toi suivi ouais comment tu le
transmet comment est perçue puis comment
il peut le vivre ensuite par lui-même
fait quoi comme quatre niveaux de toile
ouais c'est comme ça devient ultra
complexe le bain c'est sa faute ce
calcul télé years qui s'additionnent
qu'est ce qui reste là lui locales à sa
mère navale qu'est ce qui vous fait pas
grand chose au final qu'est ce qui
explique sûrement pourquoi c'est
tellement difficile de transmettre cette
idée là moi je rappelle pour revenir
quand mon coach m'a demandé d'expliquer
à tous le monde du groupe qu'est ce qui
faisait que je te vois ce que j'ai dit
c'est
sa part des abdos puis c'est la seule
chose que je trouvais qu'ils étaient
pertinentes à dire pour quelqu'un puisse
comprendre que le mouvement partait pas
des gens sa partie du site puis offert
sa peau sûrement pas porté fruit tant
que ça parce que c'était c'est beaucoup
plus complexe que ce tir mais c'est
d'essayer de trouver j'imagine ce ce que
tu me dis le justement développer cette
heure-là d'été des comics créé comment
faire résonner telle chose c'est le
temps des interlocuteurs me hante les
mauvaises mains si c'est de la
manipulation à vincent slits c'est en
fait moi je pense que ce n'est que de la
manipulation
les interactions humaines ce n'est que
sur les humains sont faits pour se
manipuler un bébé quand ça mais ça déjà
ça apprend manipuler sont en fait que de
nouveaux champs de texte est un
manipulateur même 100% sauf c'est
toujours qui vous auto sipilou si le
lait le beurre ni la même affaire les
caméras tamani manipule mais la question
c'est une manie est-ce que tu manipules
pour john wayne ou juste dans ton
intérêt parce que ça c'est un autre
point super intéressant qui est
dimensionné chemin en avait plus dans un
vidéo où j'écris j'écoute et que tu as
fait ou est ce que tu disais c'est une
game mais que l'on veut les deux gagner
ces faits comment est ce que tu fais
pour aller chercher le meilleur de sept
parties si le tiche pour tout le monde
le type j'imagine que c'est la wii que
la manipulation devient positive louis
puis l'interlocuteur vos façons b souci
pour te manipule et puis manipuler les
barrières d'accès fair game
puis c'était mieux équipée bêtes soient
mieux manipuler mais si je manipule
mieux pour sortir le meilleur des deux
c'est super ce comme l'autre devraient
payer pour tes d'air pur pour poulets
d'un faisceau c'est exactement ce que ça
ça marche dans une phase une chicane des
outils devront payer la communication
qui amène games puis comme si l'autre
est un adversaire
la gaine j'imagine en verre en verre
vouloir t comment même équipe comme une
game était dans même équipe faisait ça
c'est s'il le faut on a un but commun
faut y aller c'est quoi le but quand
même temps ben ça n'est pas la
conversation mais une des choses les
plus importantes saisies pourquoi qu'on
se parle qu'on va investir de l'énergie
j'en sais pas il faut pas aller trop
vite vers l'avant puis trop mettre
d'énergie pour qu'on se parle déjà il
faut qu'on se soit rentable pour nous
deux de façon relativement équivalentes
vaincu you're not gains 1 mais qui place
bien fait comment je contribue à sow
comment on s'assure que il va voir du
win-win là dedans je couds consentants
sur ce jeu là lors on essaye de
travailler à faire ressortir le meilleur
avec j'avais toutes les courses qu'on
peut avoir notre l'idée c'est de gagner
à 2 parce que si on gagne en deux on
vient solidifier notre relation qui on
est comme hier on va rejouer ensemble ça
va être vraiment cool c'est sûr tu veux
jouer
on veut jouer des game win win mais dans
le sud est il de femmes à la répression
[Rires]
l'étude en mai après c'est sûr que c'est
sur quelqu'un qui connaît de travail de
savoir doit partir avec une présentation
que tu vas essayer de contrôler le
pignon dans le fond mais j'imagine que
mettons le maire exemple de ce que de ce
que tu dis je pense puis peut-être que
je me trompe car je me souviens trompe
c'est dans une chicane de couple
maintenant tête avec ton partenaire tu
as ton ou ta partenaire puis vous vous
aimez la mettons la prémisse de base la
relation c'est en une relation s
concerne puis on veut régler le problème
l'objectif c'est de régler le problème
pour que les deux on gagne dans sur fait
que j'avais que d'être capable de
contrôler puis de manipuler les codes de
la communication si ça amène à surmonter
des blocages communicationnel
probablement que si le meilleur exemple
de communes d'une manipulation politique
ne l'imaginent
oui mais c'est comme ces importantes
c'est dans les relations personnelles
il faut pas qu'il fasse plus que ton 50
pour ça il faut que tu maximiseront 50%
pour que l'autre fasse son boulot si tu
peux pas faire double job ne peut
importe les connaissances quant au faux
cloclo fasse son travail de dire ce
qu'elle veut vraiment dire de demander
ce qu'elle veut vraiment demandé puis
lobala par exemple moi je vois c'est
d'avoir la meilleure écoute passé pour 4
chez exactement qu'est ce qu'un jeudi
puis pourquoi ce qui est sûr qu'on se
comprend pissos je suis quand même des
fils à se comprendre c'est pas si simple
que seul ce com pourquoi tu insistant
que sur cette affaire lors pourquoi tu
me gausse avec surtout le tant qu'etat
classe est important se rendre compte
que finalement on comprend rien
c'est la première belle et à ce qu'on
essaie de comprendre vite ça marche pour
parce que ça inhibe toute les processus
d'écouté mais quand on s'aperçoit que
finalement je comprends pas vraiment
mais là la games com ans puis le style
femme parce que l'on a quelque chose à
écouter on veut aller saisir l'essence
de ce que l'autre veut dire et ça c'est
intéressant ça veut dire que mon à job
c'est d'écouter le mieux possible mais
sa job à l'autre personne c'est de me le
dire que plus de précision possible à
deux ans pc de mieux le définir de mieux
le trouver jusqu'à temps qu'on fasse à
date csc puis là on a comme les des bons
matériaux de construction pour après se
construire la solution me soit on va
trouver de sa solution ça abril la
nature de ce qu'on veut vraiment se dire
on est beaucoup trop rapide sur les
solutions on est spécialisée en
solutions
ses seules écoles à l'école c'est
résoudre rapidement s'il souhaitait
points mais des dialogues ça marche pas
dialogue c'est ben trop c'est bien trop
profond avec foutu prennent du temps
pour bien saisir ce que la personne veut
dire pense pourquoi disent oh que c'est
que ça veut dire c'est quoi les liens là
dedans c'est ce qui est intéressant
max hit escamote cette partie là toutes
les matériaux de construction qui créent
des des solutions comme tu dis à long
terme d'après matériaux secs c'est pour
ça qu'il faut recommencer tout temps les
mains conversation puis on se tue à
parler des mêmes sujets qui deviennent
tabou c'est ça que tu disais tu parlais
dans une autre vidéo 2
construire la relation avant d'aborder
le sujet donc la relation soit assez
solide pour le sujet peut tuer l'abhorré
sur ce way un sujet de conversation aux
différentes connotation émotionnelle
la plupart des sujets importants
comporte une bonne dose d'anxiété aucune
plaie différents facteurs qui vont faire
en sorte que le chef conversation va
être très puissant émotionnellement très
anxiogène que pendant qu'on veut être
grossier pour parce que ça reste quand
même beaucoup de théorie puis qu'on veut
mettre on veut garder une une
un exemple rendant nos discussions le
temps qu'on va être grossier tu es dans
une relation de couple
il ya eu une tromperie ce sujet-là et
l'éléphant dans la pièce on veut en
parler on veut résoudre
ouais ultra chargé émotionnellement où
je serai un bris de confiance justifiant
10 confiance ok combien de fois tintin
com
ouais j'ai vu ton téléphone je veux pas
le regarder mais je veux qu'on a vu un
message dans l'exceptionnel doute une
grosse un gros sujet c'est un énorme
succès pour syndicaux ok c'est ça tu
fais quoi avec cela ouais en fait comme
un rat en fait aux impôts de série on
vas tu penses que ça ça l'a fait la job
la ccnt mort c'est fini c'est cela c'est
grave juste pour rire en dessous du
tapis ça va augmenter parce constitué de
l'évitement émotionnelle sur un sujet
qui est chargée émotionnellement c'est
sûr qu'ils se transfère à d'autres plus
les deux développent de l'hyper
vigilance c'est à dire qu'on voit plus
de la menace encore plus rapidement plus
loin des deux côtés donc les deux
commencent à bâtir de la méfiance est
donc l'anxiété relationnel augmente des
deux côtés ta relation crache plus la
libido plus toutes les systèmes
émotionnel ils vont avec
puis je sa cause de quelque chose qu'on
n'a pas été capable d'aller jusqu'au
bout de ça peut partir d'une niaiserie
un souvent sa part de niaiseries munier
is rich est une patate chaude unis
indique une patate chaude que tu laisses
trust a garanti que c'est comme une
carte de crédit chaque pièce voir si sa
carte jusqu'à tacler 8-6 face le civil
c'est sûr ça c'est ce qu'on appelle le
point de non-retour relationnel à ce que
la saccharose puis on n'est qu'à c'est
terminé je suis capable et c'est fini
par me comble regardons ça sort d'où
ça sent d'une accumulation et un moment
donné que jamais c'était exactement que
ça compte ça contaminé plusieurs sujets
sains qu'imagine sûr c'est un sujet
c'est un sujet maintenant un petit
message texte rien une lotte cumule une
autre affaire où ce que par exemple pas
voulu faire quelque chose pour elle où
elle n'a pas voulu faire quelque chose
pour tout autre sentiment que ça devrait
être le sait pas parce que tout auteur
hockey sur un autre site enfants que tu
sois pas aborder ces deux petites nizri
mais les couples ou les relations
longtemps il y en a mais comme ça à
manier le tout devient le tout sclérosé
ça devient tout à ce touché puis la
salle à la relation devient saturé ça
c'est un exemple de sujet en changer
l'élément dans le fond qu'il l'a un peu
la colle d'une relation autiste qui
tient son ensemble c'est la confiance
allemand oui dit qu'un élément de
confiance qui prisaient ici pour régler
c'est un peu le début de la phase finale
si tu laisses aller oui oui c'est sûr
mais c'est pas si facile que ça
retrouver de la confiance parce que déjà
détruit vite mais ça se construit
lentement voilà russe qui la seule façon
qu'on soit la confiance il faut aller
jusqu'au bout du sujet faut sentir que
mutuellement on le comprend on le
maîtrise qui on en a plus peur en
chaussé les patins juste le 90% du monde
se rendent même posté dans l'eau un
couple dessous tu fais ok maintenant
qu'on a apprécié que c'est que ça veut
dire
remettons con mais tant qu'on des
quartiers parce que je joue vraiment con
qu'on fasse cette conversation autre
façon assez concrète le concret at puis
qu'on puisse bild et sur des choses
acquises m comment est-ce que tu
trembles 6,6 à 90% du monde qui se
rendent pas
parlons pas dessus de 10% comment on
fait pour se rendre lundi pour aller au
bout de cette question là oui quels sont
les mécanismes de communication qui
permettent de mieux comprendre ce que
j'imagine qu'il ya beaucoup de de
laisser légaux à la porte pour être
capable d'entrer dans le convention de
façon le plus neutre possible et qui
commence construire
il y en a beaucoup disent qu'ils sont
nécessairement parce que ça les petits
sujets en dessous du sujet c'est énorme
aborder ce ça prend beaucoup beaucoup
d'habileté hockey
première affaire juste l'attention il ya
une structure attentionnel ce que
j'appelle une architecture est
intentionnel consciente
un manager en deux personnes c'est à
dire qu' il faut que les deux personnes
aient le même focus intentionnel à
chaque instant de la conversation
ce ça veut dire maintenant de tout et
mon job l'on se parle on lit le mais
quelque chose à aborder
- si je te parle de quelque chose ça
veut dire que moi je m'attends que ton
attention conscience aussi strictement
dédiés à moi ça ça veut dire que pour se
poser et réfléchir pendant que je te
parle
le ton du brouage facile mais les gens
doivent pas entre legend of han 1,5 et 3
secondes d'attention consciente de sa
vedette pendant je te parle depuis ton
attention sur moi il ya différents
mouvements qui va arriver par exemple
analysé ce que tu fais le un fax mais
sol
moi je te le dit verbalement mais tous
les humains sont très sensibles à ce lot
c'est en tout trois airs pour voir son
est en sécurité ou pas pendant qu'on
parle à quelqu'un
ok d'action sans qu'on manque de cuman
ne sais pas ce que ton attention va
commencer à flickr et ça doit alterner
en ce que je te dis [ __ ] ta réponse
on va commencer à voir de l'alternance
attentionnel tactique ils mangeront
changé dans respiration va changer ton
visage vous devenez plus rigide de
yoplait ya plein d'affaires des épaules
vont monter il ya un packaging que
automatiquement cependant rendre
conscient ce fait ils m'écoutent pas si
sûr c'est que c'est dans ce qu'on se dit
capable de même si tu ne maîtrises pas
tout ce que tu viens d un sens de mer
dont le symbole en cas de ressentir que
la personne devant nous nous écoute pas
parce tout ces systèmes le qui ensemble
nous envoie signal oui donc si moi
j'essaie de t'expliquer quelque chose ça
faisait que moi là je prends des choses
je te fais le travail d'essayer de
mettre des choses sur la table si toi tu
connectons attention sur toi ça faisait
qui est en train d'utiliser mon véhicule
pour métaboliser temps la réponse que tu
vas revenir compte moins avec ce service
n'est pas prêt de meech l'utiliser avec
mon stock ni terne
soit c'est juste en divisant ton
attention juste son attention se diviser
au mauvais moment
la conversation ne peut plus évoluer et
le cerveau prend la décision de dire sur
quoi on va pas leur toiture respecte
superficiel et c'est comme ce comptable
jamais des bons sujets c'est à dire 80 %
des chicanes de couple ne portent pas
sur le bon sujet de conversation et ça
c'est ultra intéressant puis est ce
qu'on est capable de désamour de
déconstruire cette espèce de steam et on
le sent mettons quand j'te quand je te
parle
[Musique]
changer plus mon attention que beaucoup
de gens à qui on parle mais prend pas ce
que tu as réussi à te déconstruire ce
mécanisme le de back and forth de
conscience
oui c'était à force de pratiquer tu fais
comme le spa moi j'ai pas travaillé le
jeu pas trouvé une réponse le hockey
mais mettez les humains ça veut juste
bien faire c'est essayer de trouver des
réponses justes pour essayer de
contribuer à des loteries qui on se met
une pression de résoudre quelque chose
mais à force de pratiquer tu fais ça
marchera pas cette réponse le leur il
s'agit de comprendre qu'est ce que l'on
est en train de dire c'est un as pour
moi donc un tu as prend fin ce sport
l'autre comme si tu modifies un peu ta
technique de nage trop des bus pour
confortable dans leurs offres
je serai comme l'instant c'est plus
facile ça avance bien plus vite me fous
tu parles porter ces petites enveloppes
la pression de change ta technique qui
l'homme a mené dimanche plus vite le
sien c'est long avant que ce soit payant
je pense qu'après technique de me le
faire au crâne a maintenu son air simple
chez techni je ferai appel en était au
début de la titre j'ai vraiment eu un
déclic d'affaires la junte avait dit ok
je sors le coude et glee selon l'ong
julie plus tard échangés so secondaires
savaient prix tu avais je me rappelle
très bien je pense que je m'appelle soit
11 de plus que si jusqu'à moi mais je
rappelle au début la saison tu es tu en
étais ayons vraiment craché je me
rappelle t elle
ça marche pas puis chaque fois c'est
redevenu tough en entraînement sur ton
bâton cl de mardi
joanne k records et là dessus et afin
dernière compétition p2 ton troll et moi
la question qui me vient c'est parce que
c'est vraiment passionnant mais si
justement comment dit on est partis
tantôt de dépenser natation mais il ya
tellement de données que tout semble
maîtrisée commentant arriver le vélo'v
s'écoute ont parcouru automne mais tant
au niveau personnel qui est peut-être
une nouveauté études ou à 9 heures
comment est il devenu la personne qui
était aujourd'hui avec tout ce bagage
suisse à savoir le mais je pense que
plusieurs volets depuis plusieurs
morceaux dans académiquement dans le
fond ces coûts parce que je sais qu'ils
mettront aston l'hystérie pitch dit m
c'est dans quel domaine numéro
psychologique est fondamental pierre
psychologie clinique puis ça j'imagine
que le lip ce dont on parle au présent
dans la communication c'est une des
choses qui étaient étudiés là dedans
mais non même pas alors quand même ça
c'est sympa c'est vrai c'est ce que je
trouvais un peu aberrant c'est qu'on
n'enseigne pas soi même pour les
étudiants au doctorat qui vont en voir
il faut voir des clients
il n'y a pas vraiment d'entraînement sur
quoi faire avec un client comment tu
l'écoutent
il ya des grosses erreurs que le monde
font j'en commence à écrire des notes
d'affaires grosse opération vraiment
comme maladie qui sont pas
nécessairement enseigne à l'université
une quitte donc sa peau j'ai pas
apprécié à l'université n'ont donc c'est
beaucoup de les crs travail personnel et
ce qui est des gens qui ont théorisé ce
oupoh vraiment oui mais en fait il ya
plus c'est quand tu lis des articles
scientifiques lé des articles
scientifiques c'est très précis sur des
mécanismes très très pied précis plat
quand ali étant les plus jeunes en une
centaine manuel il ya une tendance la
danoise et puis tu es capable de lire
entre les lignes de cette croissance est
vraiment important puis de différents
types de littérature puis à force de
lire puis d'essayer des choses
ben tu vois que il fait capable de voir
ce qui se passe pis encore une fois je
reviens la natation un moment donné
j'avais une côte une psychologue un ange
et s'il a à dire est ce moi je veux
juste marge et 30 minutes puis je veux
parler de rappeler nos jeux qui mettent
un pays n'a consenti à des cours privés
y compris vgh côte dans le dcu privé a
dit moi je vais m'arranger traduite par
les jeux mais produit par les frères
minute cependant j'ai dit à tous mais
moi je vais à beaucourt fait que donner
l'adieu tu fais tu sais que tu es autres
athlètes j'en parlais aussi au talonnage
fait non on était un athlète savait
nager loti est vrai je lance le défi
aide par leurs dix minutes avant qu'ils
rendent dans le jeu mais pourquoi je
regarde les faits être regarde les faits
qu'un voit dans l'eau choc et je veux
rien à perdre fac le les athlètes au
lieu que je fais à l'eau ça va vous
mettre ce travail sûr qu'aujourd'hui
tout
l'onssa soyez achevés on va parler les
athlètes québécois de toi et moi savons
plus comment sam par les pilotes moi je
faisais je sais écouter
j'écoutais je les écoutais manouba ok on
va aller dans l'eau puis je suis
commencé à remarquer qu il y avait de
quoi qu'il se passe et plus tu harper
plus d'étendre pluie par deux hautes une
couette qui se passe qui ce transfert
dans l'eau ils sont plus mobilisés qui
chante et qui recevait mieux mes
instructions il était capable des plus
concentré je le sais je recycle entre
les 20 minutes gens d'affaires un peu
plus personnelle qui me parlent vraiment
plus deux autres
il était meilleur dans l'eau quand je
leur parlais avant que je serais entré
dans l'eau j'ai réalisé que l'énergie ça
ce transfert
la façon dont ils communiquent avec une
personne du potentiel qui fasse rêver
lips à ce transfert d'un domaine à
l'autre puis tu vois des vrais effet
concret pso ça a été ma grande
trouvaille de dire avec avec timo avec
l'écoutent avec la relation qui peut
vraiment modules et des effets jusque
dans ce port est donc société juge
vraiment mon gros terrain de pratique le
coureur découvrir et ouais ouais mais
j'ai une histoire similaire d'après ces
petits cons pour eux étaient ex pendre
là dessus j'ai ce qu'ils pensent qu'à
eux mêmes mafate jeunes et du joker
jeunes et du conducteur mais c'est
mourir en fait j'étais plutôt l'épreuve
déjà on a une aura une d'ailleurs
bientôt on va maximiser ce temps leurs
qu'on va pratiquer le plus de choses
possibles puis on va faire la lecture à
vue enfin la technique on va faire des
tours enfants 6 e puis il y avait un
autre prof qui était dans la même école
que - qui était peut-être une dizaine
d'années plusieurs mois ses lagons cool
le thé classé élèves y arriver le puits
est beau dit comment ça vanne à naples
et rendent en couple
j'ai l'impression qu'ils faisaient juste
janvier que ses élèves ouais gérant les
pressions qui est comme ce profil fait
il fait quoi et je souhaite juste la
guette accélère
mais au concert de fin d'année ces
élèves qui étaient bons un site est bon
parce que j'ai l'impression qu'ils y
arrivent épi type t'es qui justement il
faisait une dernière un navire à moitié
moitié
mais ils ont peut-être ou moniteur dans
le court mais sont arrivés en maison
puis il y avait des passionnés par la
musique parce que parler de musique
pendant une demi-heure rites et puis
finalement son approche pitt il
avec du recul mais dont je reconnais
qu'ils étaient vraiment la meilleure que
la mienne parce qu'ils prenaient ces
temps-là il ferma c'était une dernière
d'hectares mais devenir les psychologies
je souhaite créer une relation qui crée
un monde musical
c'est vraiment beau mais mais oui c'est
mais comment tu expliques sera
finalement si tu parles allen confiance
qui qui est avec toi si tu par la
passion du trophée de la dation sais
quoi qui faisait quitté mère dans l'eau
après 20 minutes
mon interprétation c'est définitivement
la relation c'est comme un power play
pour des humains
c'est sur 400 connecter aux autres tu es
plus fort c'est sarah hausse toutes ont
accès à thoissey dix minutes on accepter
ça augmente on court à chaque moto focus
la relation s'est définitivement gros
levier puis d'ailleurs c'est reconnu que
trois piliers à la motivation humaine la
relation la compétence puis l'autonomie
fait au moins 33 % ta variance de ton
pas où je peux dire ton sentiment
d'appartenance des relations donc c'est
non négligeable c'est pas la seule
source d'énergie bien évidemment ça
remplace pas tant son savoir-faire dans
une tente bien évidemment mais une
relation solide puissante
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
significatif c'est fascinant
j'ai une histoire similaire puis on peut
s'attarder à ce trop longtemps mais je
suivais des cours de droit même école
que toi tu te rappelles des fois même
école que tu donnais des cours de gitmo
je suivais les cadres puis des fois
j'arrive dans le décor et alex il
faisait déjà choqué des dvd des jarres
gavin harrison de poids qu pas un truc
qui dormait plus que le mot je tripe fck
manquer plus jardin chez nous j'avais
deux friches de comme je suis jamais
juste plus le drame que quand j'étais
rentré dans la course
oui bleus sans vie de travail et d'aller
de l'avant
c'est ce que j'avais cru cette connexion
là le commun on trippe devant des
demandes d'enquêté tdb meilleurs tandis
que cissé comme qui c'est sérieux au
fait la musique puis je pense le
métronome jude et je n'ai pas de plaisir
qu'elle n'est pas plaisir ils voient ça
reviendra question ce comme la métaphore
du pont avec le sujet ces points
c'est ce faire un mirande dans l'eau ou
attendre homme fit ont pas en dessous le
reste ça va passer dessus plus tu veux
manger vite plus âpre un gros pas un sou
à un lien fort puis tu veux faire tu
veux créer du dépassement chez quelqu'un
faut-il considérer comme un gros sujet
anxiogène parce que plus tu écris du
déplacement plus savait difficile plus
tu vas avoir peur de l'échec c'est à
dire de pour réussir parce que c'est ce
qui va arriver mais qu'est ce qui fait
en sorte que tu vas avoir quand même de
l'énergie pour deux mois je lâche pas
c'est on penser la relation teint ouais
puis cette relation le comment comment
on la construit concrètement ses dents
avec tous les gens qui nous entourent on
a toujours dit que l'on donné l'exemple
d'un couple mais ça peut être aussi avec
des amis quand un sujet anxiogène gamme
comme tous l'appellent
et le quels sont les mécanismes pour
vraiment belle désire quelque chose puis
comment est ce qu'on sait qu'on est prêt
à aborder un sujet anxiogène
comment est ce qu'on sait que la
relation est assez élevé mais tant qu'on
reprend encore l'exemple du texte c'est
qu'est ce qu'on sait qu'on est prêt à
parler de ce puits comment on en parle
comment est ce qu'on fait c'est en fait
à tout aussi puis très provocation mais
juste ajouter une partout c'est
justement on ne soutient pas les ponts
pourraient aller partout où l'essai on a
vu le contre exemple en fait de comment
gérer la situation du texte mais après
tout on pourrait aussi développer c'est
quoi en fait moi exemple ce soit de
manager six ans serait pas au bout de
cinq ans si le couple c'est vrai c'est
chez je parle plus souvent de saut avec
des filles parce que c'est un petit peu
plus de filles qui s'inscrit maintenant
dans des workshops des choses comme ça
mais des jeunes gosses c'est moins salah
parle moins souvent malheureusement
france est rendu là dessus nous on en
attendre la proche 30 jusque là fait des
relations à cause de communication
massif et j'imagine que plus au courant
d'aucun point je ne sais plus et plus
vif le même temps je suis vraiment
capable de dire thomas quitte elle prend
une communication dans telles relations
ça a causé les problèmes la fin puis
c'est l'expérience qui s'était avant
d'ajouter c'est gênant je trouve surtout
l'important la conversation puis il ya
des sujets que j'aurais aimé ça aborder
avec vous aux routes mais on pardonne
tout à fait je me sens qu'on parle d'eux
concernant mais oui en cours de
sexualité sympa j'ai un gros problème
avec la façon dont ça bordello sanguine
à ses papiers d'un mauvais en place pour
ce travail est tout à fait ça pour ça ok
effectif en commun comment met-on dans
l'exemple du texte comment est ce qu'on
sait que la converse la relation ouais
ok rendu assez forte à s'est construite
pour être capable d'aborder un sujet
anxiogène quitte en quittant un niveau
comment qu'on sait qu'on est au bon
niveau puis comment est-ce qu'on traite
situation qu'il ya deux questions là
dedans 1 comment bartier de la relation
il faut comprendre la relation
c'est un système de compensation la
relation humaine
c'est comme un filet de sécurité que tu
fais pour compenser la vulnérabilité
donc si tu veux créer de la relation il
faut que manient la vulnérabilité seul à
venir habiter qui fabrique la relation
dont cerveau peut pour synthétiser de la
relation humaine ni l'autre peut pas
synthétiser de la relation pour toi
comme ça donc ce qu'il faut manier c'est
pas la relation une conséquence de
processus de vulnérabilité donc ce qu'il
faut faire c'est capable de stimuler le
maximum de vulnérabilité de façon
réciproque si tu fais ce là la relation
qu'on mette ont encore trois puits - la
relation comme je vous l'aï trouvée pour
toi la relation que tous les privés où
ils prouvaient pour moi va se suivront
va avoir sur le plu réciproquement
possible parce qu'il n'y a pas seulement
une relation en dégustant un genre de
troisième parti indépendant une
projection que moi je fabrique surtout
appuyé une projection que tout se
fabriquent sont moins cm exactement égal
égal ok mon voeu sur le plus réussi pour
les prêts si ces deux lignes parallèles
curieusement direction ouais c'est ça et
donc ça veut dire que dans tes processus
de communication souvent avant le pont
le plus fort pour aborder le sujet ça
veut dire qu'il faut être très très fort
pour augmenter la vulnérabilité avec une
personne de façon réciproque et c'est
pas si facile que soit passée très
capricieux la vulnérabilité parce que le
cerveau et calculs toujours les risques
dans la quête par quand il y aborde un
sujet et c'est très facile que celui
qu'on tourne sous le nom fut nouveau pic
hd afin qu'ils y avaient mis sa voix
dans sa tête qui change au sujet me pose
une question est vrai exemple qui est un
exemple mais mettons d'éviter certains
sujets ce qu'était qui change
complètement un mec là dessus
jeudi par exemple aurait mon ex je l'ait
trompée par exemple avec une nouvelle
relation cesse plus de faire de
l'évitement de ce sujet là parce que tu
dis qu'il ya un risque que ceux ci a
divulgué cette information
exactement un exemple mais le cerveau
même qu'en tant il y en a pas conscience
l'a65 ya pas les conditions de
vulnérabilité puissant que le potentiel
de rejet de son partenaire est trop
élevé de se mouiller vos pas et diminue
la vulnérabilité ça faisait qui
sélectionne les sujets de conversations
les plus important c'était les plus
vulnérables qui aimait sa glace puis
seront pas que c'est c'est dans ta
conversation donc une sélection de ce
qui rend accessibles pour l'autre
personne
donc si les deux personnes ayant le
maximum de conditions de communication
qui font en sorte que par exemple sur
wii fait ou on va le dire selon son
budget sur le messie chacun face au
dauphin façon réciproque
la relation se bile comme ça puis le
c'est là qu'on se sent de plus en plus
proche on fait quand même
ni proche plomb se sent plus courageux
jusqu'à temps qu'on fasse
ok on est vrai dit a parlé de ça mais
faut être rendu tout peut pas le forcer
les gens souvent essaye de se forcer
pour aborde un sujet parce qu'ils
veulent juste passé par suis passé à
autre chose ils veulent bien faire de le
résoudre
méthot préconditions limra jamais de
résoudre enfin qu'il faut que tu te
rends au sujet avant la façon de s'y
rendre c'est foutu bellota relations
dans conversations ce ça veut dire entre
autres fous tu saches que manier ton
attention si tu sais pas quoi écouter
qu'un situe déconnecte ans paul temps en
plein milieu par exemple qu'une personne
en le pic de vulnérabilité à ce moment
là le sanctionner fini le personnes
viendront pub qui enregistre une dette
personnes voient petit cochon c'est
subtil ces affaires là la personne va
juste comme arrêtée par les puits avons
cherché à se refermer
c'est et voilà vous en personne va le
sentir tout moment quand on est ouvert
tout à perdre sa tête est plus la
vulnérabilité devient élevé plus les
arts sont fatales
françois très précis puis je pense que
l'idée c'est faut prendre conscience du
potentiel humain qui a dans une tête à
quel point ces dips et puis 50 personnes
commencé à divulguer des affaires
considèrent que c'est de l'or ouais
touche pas à ça c'est pas ton en
protégeant mettez ça dans un coffre
je peux pas faire comme moi avons le
monde vont ça nous coûte pour sujet le
monde se mêle de ses affaires et
maintenant tout se dit quelque chose
moi je pense que constate à waimes aussi
déjà vécu ce que c'est ça c'est là que
c'est la chose qu'on entend depuis qu'on
fait le plus souvent oui de prendre la
personne te raconte quelque chose puis
automatiquement ton cerveau s'en va vers
un souvenir que taux qui est similaire
ou pas ça tu passes 15 secondes la fin
de la conversation de la personne à
réfléchir à ton anecdote que tu veux
raconter le théâtre était d'à côté
complètement de ce concept mais si tu
peux le lire un visage avant la
personnalité puis leurs deux enfants
étant jusqu'ici lance la personne x way
moussilou a changé chez warp une
question what donne un conseil s'est
tout dé même c'est tout les mêmes
erreurs factuelles mais on se met les
pieds d'un plot un peu n'importe quand
avec le monde font jeu sur fermi fakty
où tu vas aller d'après toi d'un gros
sujet de conversation vous voulez vous
allez parler de soi de la confiance avec
ton texte aux éléments de la route
je ne mets pas capable d'aborder un
sujet 500 erreur c'est impossible c'est
mécaniquement l'eau c'est impossible
impossible aux essais techniques au
boutte
c'est drôle tire pas de concept d'apprêt
ctc comme facile on dirait deux
m trouver des montées moment de sa vie
où est-ce que des erreurs comme son
étape qui me je me suis ni trade jamais
descendre des dizaines qui m'ont pas
parlé il ya tellement dépit je me suis
très bien que d'avoir vécu mettons ce
c'est une personne avec touches contre
une relation pile à un moment précis du
tout sur quelque chose que pour toi est
ce pas la porte à la personne fait une
blague avec souffrance par là les gens
puissent réellement il ya eu un jour des
déclics de son peuple on peut comprendre
on peut construire ces moments que je
mouille pour moi c'est super important
c'est ça c'est vraiment comme se disent
la cible d'un bloc ce type ici pour
passer au niveau 6 ans si on bloque à ce
niveau là c'est sûr c'est exactement ce
que le cerveau y teste avec des plus
petits sujets au début le cerveau pagora
chez ton plus gros or ce qui vaut le
plus cher de toit au début il va tester
du cracking jeunesse à atteindre 10 km
écouter cette escapade de respecter ce
sur une superbe photo d'elle
l'approprier
souvent tu me le piquer plomb ils
testent puis dépendamment de si on passe
le test avec ce il fait ok ça pense on
augmente la valeur de ce que tu mets sur
la table saison nettement ce lundi ce de
vulnérabilité mais c'est sûr que plus ça
avance plus ça vaut cher pas que c'est
ce que tu m'as encore plus d'être absent
à table donc les petits sujets houleux
ce matin dans les conversations c'est
pas du ciment tagbana c'est conteste nos
règles du jeu une honte est ce en août
soit un sport qui sécuritaire au pot 6
po sécuritaire enfin ça va être avec toi
27 ans que l'on se bat dans une relation
de même que la passe rien fuck up
quesnel fa cups parce que c'est comme un
gros sujet elle vous est même pas au
stade 2 je vais pas passer à travers ce
fait le site pour ça que là il ya
tellement des gros gap que c'est là que
les gens se laissent mais c'est pas
parce qu'il n'a pas de potentiel
ensemble c'est une question ce qu'ils
achètent en danger fait que je finis un
instant je vous dis ça se règle ça
s'adresse enfin c'est pas oui quelque
chose de personnel la d'années ces
sportifs la communication puis moi
j'aborde source
comme du sport dans l'intention de
vraiment vraiment c'est tellement ce
parce que mettons la compréhension de
quelque chose
la compréhension d'un trouble
communicationnel lorsque toi tu
verbalise on le tout ce véhicule puis de
le mettre en mots on dirait que ça
éclaire sur beaucoup de choses
quand je débute une relation avec
quelqu'un ce sont nos relations d'amitié
ou une relation amoureuse puis que pour
une raison pour une autre puis prend la
main que tu serais capable de le
verbaliser pour une raison ou pour une
autre il ya des affaires que t'es pas
prêt à dire ou que tu sens que tu peux
pas dire dans cette relation là tu sais
qu'il ya un problème mais en fait ce que
moi je me dirais mettons tout ce que je
me disais avant conséquent je pars
aujourd'hui c'est cette relation mais
pas nécessairement possible parce que je
suis pas à l'aise de dire certaines
affaires fait que si je parlais de dire
certaines affaires ça veut dire qu'il ya
pas une fin de ce1 ou si ça pourra pas
de démarrer mais la réalité c'est que
c'est beaucoup plus haut niveau
communicationnelle de dire à qui
peut-être qu au niveau où on sait pas
vraiment compris c'est fascinant
en fait c'est là les créations de tabou
de lady tantôt le cac est un sujet aux
attentes et les autres sur le sujet on
ne fera pas un mur ça se peut qu'on y
retourne plus jamais c'est sur picasa
accumulent et abouti il ya des gens sont
là des relations moi même j'étais dans
des relations ou est-ce qui est
tellement tabou que tous les besoins du
marché des zus sur tous les sujets dont
j'ai peur c'est ce qui se sait pauvre et
c'est un cauchemar
si la définition d'un court peu de cette
un coach dans une relation où esker a
fait ça va paraître cliché mais en fait
tu peux plus être toi - ouais tu y as tu
pu être comme un cas typique exprimer ce
que tu penses ce que tout ça ce qu'est
ce que tu vis parce que tu seras
toujours un mur parce que c'est toujours
mal interprétés parce que c'est toujours
c'est la définition d'un cauchemar
ben oui c'est c'est très léger qui sont
pauvres la maison là je dis ça ça mange
tellement d'énergie parce que quand je
retourne à la maison c'est là où tu très
chargé tu veux parler tu es bien il faut
que ce soit sécuritaire si tu tombes
chez vous petit travers encore à ne pas
marcher sur des oeufs puis titouan qui
fait ce travail là de décortiquer
comprendre si tu dois le reconnaître
suit une relation où est ce que une
dynamique comme ceux s'installe sur le
reconnaître tu vas dire moi je peux pas
évoluer dans une relation comme ceux
probables mais quelqu'un qui ait jamais
réfléchi à ce ou ces prêts en x qui vit
se scellait des fautifs et comment
affirmer la zone relation qui te
convient pas du tout mettez taper les
mots de paul les connaissances pour le
nommer pour le reconnaître
faris souvent c'est vraiment complexe
dans les relations de couple parce que
l'on parle de stratégie de communication
mécanismes de création mais plein de
choses qui t'attire dans un couple c'est
des gros symbole le cpo c'est vraiment
puissant trio l'attirance sexuelle est
la valeur du regard de l'autre sur toi
que tu repères biya c'est vraiment ces
immenses que il ya plusieurs standards
possible dans un couple dépendamment le
où tu es rendu puisque tu vis dans le
couple mais
c'est ce que construire une relation ça
passe par de la communication
mais il ya des coupes que c'est pas
fondées l'atuge de dire est assez fondée
sur le fait que ça me rassure de sortir
avec sept personnes à ce genre de
personne ment parce que j'aime l'image
que je me donne qui on aime l'image
qu'on se donne mutuellement
je sois beaucoup ok mais aussi bonnes
relations sexuelles pour toi le bain
c'est que tu peux tu peux être fier de
sortie avec une personne qui ça peut
flatter son égo petit pet attirer puis
c'est comme tu peux le trouver sexy 6 pi
6 po est débile c'est josé c'est tous
des choses belles correct lors les
choses tangibles qui sont aux électeurs
bah oui c'est bien correct mais faut que
tu comprennes que votre or comme bâtir
une relation aussi sûr c'est pas le même
trip
rexie tu comprends que ces deux tribus
différentes investi des deux bons jeux
dray est cool j
mais si tu confonds les deux aides en
armes et on dit le plein de points de
flash relation passée qu'est ce que je
fais c'est j'aborderai définitivement
différemment est-ce que souvent dans ma
vie en fait j'ai dû aborder des sujets
pour lequel la conversation était juste
pas rendu le 6 mai dont je suis pas si
j'ai envie d'aller tentant d'en dans le
concret xul métier mettons des fois de
com de quoi qui est ultra important pour
toi que tu va aborder mais quand même
pas franchi la porte d'entrée de ce
niveau conversationnel des pilotes
abordent ce mets tu laborde tout croche
complètement tout croche
puis ça fait juste que ça empire le
problème c'est parce que c'est là qu'il
faut travailler en équipe le 6e
c'est une personne va s'exprimer à la
hauteur de la réception la personne qui
est une machine d'écouté qui coûte
vraiment quand même kingpin working le
souhait parler
parce qu'un humain cinq sources confient
justice et safe
mais si c'est ce que ces seuils qui je
veux parler des soins
je te dirais c'est beaucoup une question
de l'habileté des côtes d'une personne
même personne qui écoute bien là je lui
parle puis c'est comme avec elle ça a
passé je n'ai jamais réussi à dire sur
pierre que je me suis trouvé clerc bien
que sont ces compris ses seules écoutes
l'écoutent c'est la fin la plus
importante était au début quand on
raconte une personne
alors maintenant on a des habiletés un
jeu pas de communication base ensemble
ok jusqu'à maintenant posera et le
faudrait avancer nous faudra se
perfectionnant pelade d'ailleurs je me
souhaite partager des affaires pas que
ça faudrait discuter ensemble de que
j'en écoute on a besoin puisqu'elle gère
la communication a besoin d'un coup
qu'on clarifie sommes informés des
nouveaux sujets c'est ça évolue mais
pour être parfait seul comme cela dans
l'axé quand même et on veut temps sans
marquer mais on va souvent on veut
maximiser nos conditions c'est ce qu'ils
font en coupe c'est que céline et l'ès
tu peux tout le temps amélioré des
affaires puis je toutes les skieuses de
communication france on connaît le goût
de se parler plus qu' on se découvre
plus notre des nouvelles solutions d
afin qu'on n'aurait jamais pensé ou
conçu un deux puis tu fais c'est quoi
c'est pour ça que je n'en scrute couple
parce que c'est sur la construction
c'est seulement des fêtes ensemble puis
l'heure sur sa gauche à la difficulté je
trouve cette étendue dit tu peux pas
faire puisque 50% de la john mois puis à
discuter je trouve en coupe
une des difficultés si qu'un conflit
acquis à qui la faute en guillemets dans
ce qui est des fois il ya un premier
communication toi tu vas dire ok mais
peut-être quelque chose de pas correct
de chasse momo bout de chemin
pis ça voyez où le 50 pour ça c'est
expressivement d'ici je trouve parce que
des fois tu peux faire 80 % et encore le
sentiment de faire passer des facteurs
qui est fait à 50% dans certains font de
fait 15% des savoirs du problème est ce
que c'est moi
est ce que c'est juste est ce que c'est
cc c'est une espèce de
un candidat excessivement difficile à
percevoir
oui c'est vraiment dur tu sais comme
steam mais dont moi dans ma vie
personnelle c'est sûr que j'utilise
toutes les affaires que je peux le faire
pour aider ma propre relation puis il
faire en sorte que l'eau soit bien plus
autant que mon choix bien mais quand tu
es dans situation spam un gain de 8-4
émotionnellement le cdur c'est
aujourd'hui c'était le cas qui borde la
partie
le fait d'avoir des skills a fait pour
tout ça te rend plus vulnérables au site
j'ai aussi peur que quand j'avais 8 ans
d'abord d'aider à faire mais je me dis
relaxe fait soeur sarah ben halima faire
fois cette affaire importante à quinte
plongé dans les affres important tu veux
revivre les mêmes émotions mais c'est
correct c'est pas un défaut par an tout
puis moi je veux pas vos - pas de parler
des sujets délicats objets même père le
cas vers c'est juste que je me dis ça va
bien aller cela fonctionne et a parfois
mais je suis partie un fact it
il ya quelque chose d'humain là dedans
que tu veux pas tu veux pas être joli
pic au dessus de quoi que ce soit
toujours pas de déshumaniser ou de
protéger avec des screens
je rentrais date fin cameron en vivent
des affaires importantes la maquette et
c'est ça que je trouve intéressant cette
année je lisais je sais pas mais je
lisais follow up là dessus ce genre
d'article de vulgarisation scientifique
qui disait que les humains on us en
espèces d'habilité des fois c'est des
fous tu vas voir un couple méthode a mis
ensemble que met on a mis plus sa
nouvelle blonde fait on peut s'affaisser
montre le pauvre playtex filet où elle a
vu où tu rencontres un couple la
première fois des des étrangers ou
quelqu'un d'extérieur vaudra plus apte à
apercevoir des fois c'est quelque chose
qui cloche innovation c'est maintenant
tu es un ami très comptable on dit il me
semble leur dynamique est spécial et oui
le train puis choqué chaud que moi il ya
déjà quelqu'un que passé ce puits
justement quand aidé à vous c'est
vraiment plus difficile de recoller qui
est dynamique pragmatique quatre à
l'extérieur tu passes une soirée qu'un
coupe tu dis non les quelque chose dans
la mythique club
nous est tous arrivé on a tous étaient
des deux côtés de cette histoire ok tu
es chez toi tu le sais pas tu vois ça
fait le lien avec l'autre question que
tu pourrais te dire on est quand même
comment tu sais que tu es vraiment fait
mon 50 % ouais ce congrès a servi un peu
la sauce que oui la course 2 - suède à
cause de l'eau jusqu'au rez comment ça
se fait que les autres équipes ils
expriment ce qui est juste bien exprimé
où ça a été mal interprétés elle a été
mal et que si celle ci le la personne qu
pas compris ce que je voulais dire est
ce que c'est moi qui le mal exprimée ou
est-ce que c'est l'autre personne qui
l'a mentionné non je pense dans un
premier temps c'est impossible
communiqué parfaitement si c'est
l'intention qui compte on arrête avec ça
moi je fais le maximum à ton âme et
conscience là de faire le best d'attica
que c'est une des choses la perfection
ce existe pas puisque devront improviser
l'autre chose comment comment savoir si
tu en as fait assez ou pas trop petit
show c'est il faut que tu te demandes
est-ce que j'ai pris l'entièreté de mes
responsabilités si tu évalues cui t'es
pas mal at-on 50
si tu commences à faire plus tu vas
commencer à travailler sur les
responsabilités de l'autre et c'est là
que tu dois pas aller
c'est là que tu dépassant 50% si tu veux
prendre les responsabilités que l'on
n'est pas capable de prendre parce que
c'est plus arrangeant pour toi de là
sauvé par exemple ben c'est loupé en
fait trop fait que le le défi c'est dire
je prends de toutes mes responsabilités
au complet clean et c'est sûr que je
peux faire mais je suis capable de vivre
avec les conséquences de saut et si
l'autre les propos ne peut pas les
prendre c'est ça marchera jamais
l'enfant est tantôt donnes tu disais je
dis est ce qu'on est juste un mauvais
film est donc en posant des questions
par rapport à ce que ça existe un
mauvais fit communicationnel parce que
moi mettons dans ma vie ça m'est arrivé
d'aller dans les tarifs de dtz arrivé de
voir quelqu'un faire acquis là ça passe
pas puis l'arrivée devant quelqu'un
d'autre faire ok là ça passe est ce que
c'est juste
ma capacité ou la capacité d'autres
personnes de bien de bien m'exprimer
bien écouter ou est-ce que des fois
carrément il ya c'est un march qui
fonctionne pas au niveau de la
communication que ça existe des matches
qui fonctionne pas c'est parce qu'on a
tous déjà vécu une dette ou est-ce que
le généraliste classement mais mettons
notre grande beaucoup de personnes que
j'ai rencontrées dans ma vie beaucoup de
mardi autant pour elle que pour tous et
c'est un peu mal elle ou l'huile peut
importe peu importe ton orientation
sexuelle mais autant pour l'autre
personne que pour toi tu dis ça poste
puis s est ce que c est ce que c'est
tous ces problèmes de communication le
pourrait dans l'absolu a été réglé mais
ton carnet qui ne touchait que derrière
un miroir à deux faces puis qui nous
regardent qui dit à qui l'on veut
refaire cette interaction l'homme est
tout à fait attention a surtout fait un
tué ce que toutes les relations
pourraient dans l'absolu être coach lui
est bien bien ouais être coaché jao bien
marché ou est ce qu'il ya des types de
personnes des choses qui sont juste un
mauvais match que ça existe un mauvais
match des couilles et ça existe un
mauvais match
ok ça dépend des attentes qu'on aura
aussi parce que un match c'est un match
par rapport à croire qu'on vise
il est important de me dire un match
mais avec quelle idée en tête parce que
ton match sur une comparaison et puis
c'est avec quelque chose qui est
important dans un match d'un objectif
des réseaux que ce soit conscient ou pas
ton match c'est une évaluation de
l'écran par les barrages
la situation présente est juste
important de la relation qui sont
différentes
voilà plus large mais tant qu'on joue
martin petit peu ce concept là c'est
aussi un concept on peut appliquer à
toutes les sphères de notre ville
oui quand tu veux quelque chose en échec
ce un échec par rapport à quoi par
rapport à un absolu
ouais tout ce que tu fais c'est ce
régime cambodgien est là tout n'est pas
bonne baisse par rapport à quoi
et peut-être bonne mais pas mal par
rapport à evans et inversement prête à
l'ultra conques et c'est tout
gdo coop écrit les la tabbee odendaal
160 star c'est tout simple mais les
attentes c'est vraiment importantes et
puis mais oui il ya des personnalités
qui marche moins ensemble c'est
l'attirance physique d afrique c'est
comme cela c'est sûr c'est josé certains
autres c'est pas ton affaire je voudrais
on a le droit d'être neuve sur des
affaires qu'on impose puis c'est correct
jeudi on n'a pas besoin c'est pas parce
qu'on est superficiel puis non pas du
tout nous on a le droit de ne pas être
attiré par des shows est une chose
par contre moi je pense que oui tout est
copiable je pense que quand les
processus sont là sur vivre quelque
chose de haute avec quelqu'un va pas de
soi marienval pas ce soir tombe en amour
mais c'est surtout tu penses que si les
processus
si la technique est là pour les deux
nageurs
ça va faire quelque chose enfin bon ça
dépasse savais pas aussi des
caractéristiques individuelles je te
donne un exemple par exemple le cuit
ouais s'influencent soins cécile
influences comme en tout la vision du
monde la façon dont par ce fait son
raisonnement personnes qu à quel point
comprend vite ce que tu veux dire le
cuisse important puisqu un tabou il ya
plein de tabou le donna dans des notes
dans notre nom de l'actionnement le
puissant mais on a pu leur parler de ce
type d'industrie n'daye ton cul c'est
quoi non plus mais ça a un impact chez
les trop grandes divergences de cui sait
comment suivre même pu suivre même
pendant le dialogue
puis l'homme un temps en disant stop
parce que je sais que comme tu dis c'est
un tabou que c'est un sujet qui est qui
qui lui sera abordé en disant ce oui y'a
pas de hiérarchisation de ton de ton qi
mettons le seo sans souci les cuissons
trop différent j'imagine que là vous
rejoignez pas autant mais pas de
hiérarchie rate deux hiérarchisation au
sens où il y avait pas assez de tu peux
avoir quelqu'un avec un qi gong italien
à cuba avec un cube au pardon de
saconnex super bien oui ça faisait ça
c'est important ça c'est un gros gros
thème directement impliqués dans ce qui
se passe socialement il faut faire la
différence entre la valeur une
et les caractéristiques individuelles se
dit qu'on n'est pas tous égaux dans nos
40 autres des talents que moi j'ai posé
c'est comme ça moi j'ai des talents que
tout autre port et cetera
on est imé go dans l'hôtel ok mais si
ces corrections ça s'appelle vivre
ensemble ça s'appelle la diversité
humaine normale mais la valeur humaine
exposé est égale pour tous le moment
exactions vrai en fait soit
indépendamment de nos caractéristiques
tout le monde a droit à une valeur égale
et de vivre des relations qui sont
positives égal mais oui des différences
de caractéristiques c'est plus dur à
mixer ensemble
c'est vrai aussi que la réalité est ce
qu'on peut trop commune qui danse dans
une relation exemple tout le hall de
partie civile veut adresser un problème
tout le temps par les tamani l'autre
c'est comme ont petit à petit laissé
respirer
c est ce qu est ce qu a mené trop c'est
comme pas assez absolument
selon moi je ne pense pas que tout doit
être dit tout le temps de la faire qu'il
faut pas que ce soit il ya des affaires
faut pas parler de beaucoup ok quand les
arts en quoi bein il ya des sujets que
le cerveau aime pas parler parce que si
tu force trop dessus ça laisse annie est
née d'une fonction je te donne un
exemple
l'excitation sexuelle ou la libido faut
faire bien attention de la façon dont on
aborde ce parce que plus tu parles d'une
fonction par exemple neurovégétatives
une fonction autonome plus tu en parles
plus tu alourdit le sujet et plus ça
inhibe c'est une pression ça ramène
pression naturelle avec des affaires il
faut faire attention de dessau ça prend
de l'air dans cette affaire le soin faut
pas qu'il faut pour verbaliser ses
affaires le tout le temps je suppose que
ça soit un sujet tabou qu'on est vivant
mais une stratégie des stratégies cc
comme c'est quand tu te fais des
insomnies
ok on va parler de son insomnie que je
te donnais des stratégies de sommeil le
camp ennemi gens dormir de ce fait juste
pensé à l'insomnie
il ya des affaires que ça besoin d'air
pour le cerveau tout n'est pas toujours
verbalisable des affaires faut que ce
soit plus du comportement plus d'écouté
physique permettant dans un rapport
sexuel wifo sexe et de la communication
c'est de l'écossé mais c'est juste que
j'ai pas toujours des malls
essentiellement non verbale ensuite je
mettais un démo par dessus tout est
détruit tôt de ta magie un moment donné
tu peux pas tout le temps tout
verbaliser
décrire toute demande est petit mais
déjà une façon un peu de rugby titre it
does it up mais sait-on manade way
d'aller chercher les consentements
mais c'est une manière [ __ ]
maintenant oui quand même ben oui c'est
ça ce sommet c'est comme tête à question
c'est ce qu' on est trop communiqué oui
surtout s'ils étaient anxieux
si tu sais de tout le temps la
verbalisation past et en chips veut
toujours être assurés sur tout le temps
de servir de l'eau pour créer des sujets
puis la saint jean de losne on a senti
comme hey le tutu m'utilise pour te
rassurer ne pas de vrais sujets ça
n'avance pas mais il faut savoir
pourquoi un pourquoi on veut investir du
temps pour parler le fath faux j'ai
combien d'agressions sexuelles disent tu
dis à ton chez moi ta blonde c'est pour
moi mettons idéalement on fait l'amour
une fois par jour mais ton s'explique
l'autre à face le sam est justement ça
le précieux qui fait affirmer un frein à
son objectif de faire l'amour c'est ce
que des sujets tu sais qu'il faut
aborder m'emmener de dire qu'ils soient
là c'est quoi la satisfaction qu'on
cherche là dedans on rit tout c'est quoi
la fréquence reut c'est quoi ce coton
idéalisé coopération vraiment immense et
sétif ont nommé des affaires mais c'est
juste des fouaces comme trop britten
conversation puis de sujets ça ça nous
rapproche pas menées c'est bien c'est
bien saturé c'est ça amène une semaine
ne le parle
j'imagine que c'est le tremplin parfait
en fait pour parler de consentement de
ce que tu voulais qu'on dise que tout
alors je pense que cécile très
pertinents je pense qu'il ya deux choses
dans six dans ce sujet là puis encore
encore une fois on c'est un sujet qui
est sensible vraiment beaucoup puis avec
raison je pense que deux choses je pense
que la communication n'est pas
nécessairement verbal j'imagine pipi
dessus lui c'est parce que maintenant
quelqu'un tu vas voir des tribus acquis
avec qui tu ne parles pas de la
communication physique qui se fait puis
d'être à l'écouté de sa communication là
c'est une chose
maintenant il ya tout l'autre aspect de
se dire avec le consentement de dire
faut faut que ce soit le plus clair
possible tu es au risque de peut-être
attiser un petit peu là la passion et y
ait eu de risque et d'attiser la passion
mais d'essayer que ce soit le plus clair
possible fait comment est ce qu'on fait
pour que ce soit le plus clair possible
parce que dans les ultimes 1 le but du
consentement c'est que ce soit le plus
clair possible du fait qu'elle est le
plus clair parce qu'on ne parlait
justement dans toutes les la vague qui
utilise dans cause de ce consentement
c'est qu'il est sa titraille but oui
clair oui verbaliser clarté puis
effectivement qui peut-être des fois
posé la question ça peut créer un genre
de frein mais vaut peut-être mieux créer
un genre de frencq et de risque et
qu'elle est entendue
qu'est ce que tu en penses moi je pense
que c'est loin d'être suffisant louis
clair c'est pas du tout une bonne
solution
c'est vrai du tout du tout du tout on
est passé d'une opinion quand on est
complètement dans un champ avec soin en
fait ça prend pas un consentement
s'apprend mais les un consentement du
début à la fin
je ne sais pas mais lien oui s'aimer les
uns ku qui montre que on est deux dans
ses mélodies la seule en direction le
bon lance moment le disque au ces il ya
beaucoup de discours un cinquième est
basé sur la victimisation l'oppression
présentement lance moment c'est les
hommes faut qu'ils arrêtent de violer
les filles
ok c'est ok lego ont définitivement un
gros travail à faire première affaire
ben les gosses à des impulsions de gore
faut que ça j'ai ressource et
responsable de ses propres l'impulsion
et ça doit maîtriser son deuxièmement un
gode doit apprendre écouter un gros sac
ou de peau surtout en présence
d'impulsion donc si tu as de la misère à
écouter jeu seul sujet de conversation
python tonton attention ce n'est pas de
ma jeune créateur des excités par en
fait on ne te pas appris à gérer sur tes
conneries
ça m'intéresse même pas donc une écoute
de base que les gants en peau qui est un
gros problème seulement mais la solution
de long terme
c'est ça peut pas être 100% la job
dugourd il faut ça prend déjà de la
fille aussi et la job la fille il faut
qu'elles expriment des choses de mettre
des limites claires et sûres on parle
pas de ce volet là du tout c'est comme
si le consentement de comme arrivé un
peu par magie le concernant c'est un
meeting il faut faire plusieurs micros
meeting pendant tout le temps qu'on est
ensemble au début avant qu'on se touche
avant même qu'une proximité pendant
qu'on se touche pendant la relation
sexuelle je parle pas facilement contre
notarié le sais pas ce que je dis c'est
qu'il doit avoir une rencontre en deux
personnes qui créent des contacts qui
ont démis qu'une pointe comme ça il ya
un ajustement constant qui est fait
l'axé pas un oui à adwea comme je peux
c'est quoi c'est quoi tu veux dire c'est
plus ton problème maintenant parce que
tu es tu te dis oui ça peut changer à
tout moment c'est sous ces chiens
instinct le comble le consentement doit
être renouvelé c'est un flot de
consentement c'est un c le but c'est de
ne jamais briser la ligne du
consentement si tôt a dit oui c'est
comme c'est quoi le but exactement là
que tu as eu ton mot aux eu et c'est
correct
c'est inacceptable ce n'est pas le
consentement qu'on recherche
je pense pas que c'est l'idée qui est
avancé je pense qu'en fait dans tous ses
mouvements de d'éducation sexuelle s'est
faite à travers le mouvement de
dénonciation du mois de sensibilisation
l'idée que le consentement doit être
renouvelée puis peut être aussi retirés
à n'importe quel moment on l'entendait
il ya un élément sur lequel je tends
désaccord est ce que tu disais seuil est
qu'en ce moment on est en train de
mettre la responsabilité
préférant sur les hommes vraiment je
promène d'accord avec ça en fait je
pense que pendant longtemps ça a été
complètement l'inversé on essaie de
rétablir un petit peu le balancier
pendant longtemps il y avait il y avait
une situation et une agression qui
étaient faits puis on disait qu'ils
mettront qu'est ce que tu as
et pour envoyer ce signal pour attiser
ce qu'elles signalent t'envoyer
qu'est-ce que tu portais na na na na hey
est-ce que pourquoi tu prenais deux
seuls pourquoi c'est pourquoi c'est
pourquoi tu écoutes avait consommé donc
pendant longtemps on a blâmé la victime
plutôt que l'agresseur à pilar moment on
est en train d'essayer juste de rétablir
une genre d'équilibré que c'est aussi la
job d'hugo de s'assurer qu'ils avaient
pas quelque chose soit commis pas juste
de la phase la femme d'être sur ses
gardes tout le temps parce que les lego
lego sédégo pis c'est comme ça que ça
changera pas osé tac je ne suis pas
d'accord condren de tomber dans l'autre
côté de la balance il mais pourquoi on
parle pas de la rencontre qui le
consentement qui se pose est une
communication mais je d'accord avec toi
d'utiliser des problèmes je pense que
d'un côté les gars tu y mets ton
l'archétype où l'espèce de 10 des d'hugo
ça pas trop ses émotions tpiy contre end
et construit mais mettons principalement
c'est encore un plus et c'est maintenant
mon grand-père sainte offpi par la peau
si ma g et prendra corps c'est cette
espèce d la pile espèce de programa
chose qu'on inculque aux filles qui
doivent plaire qui doivent être des ltte
je pense que d'un côté il ya des gars
comme nick pope et d'un côté il ya des
promenades et femmes vous dit fillon qui
ont été a appris à ne pas exprimer un
désaccord un peu exprimé flamarens nom
puisse aussi juge convaincu dans
l'éducation ça va changer
je conviens qu'il est sûre avec wu
cahier de rencontre mais de là à dire
que le fardeau qui est qu'en ce moment
mais responsabilité sur les hommes je
réponds jusque là maintenant mais
mettons moche mais ce que j'entends de
ce que vous dites c'est essentiellement
l'objectif final de tout ça c'est d'en
arriver à comme tu dis une communication
constante autant verbales que physiques
puis une attention particulière à cette
communication la d2 bart
je pense qu'on peut s'entendre que ces
ultimes moments où est ce qu'on veut en
arriver mais pour en arriver là faut
revoir l'éducation depuis le début la
façon avec laquelle on qu'on se voit les
relations hommes-femmes que en attendant
d'arriver à cette espèce de réforme là
où est ce que les hommes qui sont en
physique mais plus fort qui
habituellement ont tendance à ignorer
ces signaux là sont capables d écouter
puis d'avoir cette conversation là je
pensais en attendant de se rendre là
peut-être que c'est aux autres de ce
check et plus tu es peut-être que c'est
aux gars de notre génération de femmes
qui checke nous autres on n'a pas appris
ces dialogues le on maîtrise mal c'est
qu'au delà
peut-être qu'il faut ce check un petit
peu plus parce que essentiellement c'est
nous qui commettent 95 % des agressions
etc je prends la correction dégueulasse
et dames
si on veut une relation faux split a job
là une nouvelle jobs clair que les
gaudois faire mais les filles il faut
qu'ils travaillent à moins plaire
puis plus mettre des limites claires
c'est un problème ça je fais des
formations que j'ai fait spot que
j'affiche pas toujours mais si luxe
exclusivement pour les femmes
puis beaucoup pour des femmes qui sont
victimes d'abus
on est un des seuls façon de casser sol
c'est pas qu'il puisse par des hommes
c'est qu'il faut qu'ils se rendent
compte qu'ils ont un pouvoir à elles
sont capables de dire des affaires sont
capables de mettre des limites sont
capables de dire ceci non non ça c'est
sûr c'était la fin donc ça c'est quelque
chose qui doit se retrouver dans
l'équation pour pouvoir respecter des
limites ça prend un dialogue pas juste
une partie du dialogue sinon c'est
impossible que ça progresse ça
comme dans n'importe quel couple ça
prend deux fois par mois je suis
d'accord que tin man c'est sûr
l'objectif c'est celle là qu'on veut
aller définitivement quitter quelqu'un
qui est même si mettons le non
consentement est pas verbaliser le tit
re sic intégralement l écoute quelqu'un
comme toi d'entraîner en plus le mettons
est capable de déceler ce terrien qui
justifie je pense que même si l'autre
partie fait pas son chemin de la
communication team et ont bien cru quand
une grande proportion disent que c'est
les femmes qui sont victimes
d'agressions sexuelles puis mettons de
violences conjugales
rien qui justifie que je connaisse mon
point d'en face à ma blonde
même si elle même si elle est aussi
communique mal et rien qui justifie que
moi je me rendre jusque là et puis même
chose pour dans un contexte sexuel
je me dis même si peut-être quelque
chose qui peut être exprimé si je suis
réellement légal écoute des signes puis
non verbale la personne je peux être le
voit aucun mal à expliquer quelque chose
qui fonctionne peu je sais que c'est
pour toujours
c'est pas toujours évident de lire sous
la main c'est ça c'est sûr c'est sûr que
c'est sûr et certain que plus le message
est clair
des deux côtés plus c'est moins il ya de
chances de l'embargo c'est comme ta
question c'est comme quand jusqu'où faut
faire sa job c'est où ma job tu fait de
ton maire 50% en est possible pile au
dessus on s'efforce de l'autre le fasse
aussi dans un dialogue lac c'est sûr que
si les deux personnes se faire bon un
super bon pour pour s'exprimer puis
mettre des limites pour des super bons
pour écouter ça se fait mal aux doigts
dans le nez et une interaction des frais
y en a qui est plus faible au nom qui
meilleur donc c'est plus clair mais
c'est pas toujours claires pour faire
pour faire mais des groupes avec des
égos dgo souvent se disait je ne sais
pas qu'est ce qu'il a fait à vue
je sais pas c'est comme jugé comme lui
de signer à la même terre enfin moi
faire un mouche les mets ton jeu dans le
doute
ouais enfin le pot c'est parce que ça
peut pas être juste ça prend plus de
clarté de part et d'autre je comprends
ce soit dans l'île où tu passes à la
chaux du tube man on suppose directement
la question mais moi je reviens à l'idée
que son voeu est à 2 il faut que les
deux il ya une contribution
c'est un danger de dire je comprends
votre qui des lots de balancier puis
machin mais moi je pense qualité de
relation qualité de relation il faut
penser équipe pas penser à lost à ton
tour de travailler ouais je comprends
mais si on veut vraiment être bien
ensemble il faut vraiment qu'on se parle
d'une façon continue puis c'est pas
c'est pas toujours clair c'est la ville
d'entente dans des dettes quand je
rencontre des jeunes c'est pour cela que
seul l'argent compte expliqué tim et ont
plus que les quelqu'un plus tu es
capable de décoder ces codes soyons de
la barre je pense être un contexte que
c'est peut-être la première faute
rencontré personne louis l'alcool
impliqué une sorte de contexte qui fait
que excessivement difficile pour le non
verbal puis c'est aussi excessivement
difficile d'avoir une conversation est
quelqu'un que tu connais presque pauvre
maman qu'elle tienne rencontré d'accord
avec toi que ça rend les situations
ambiguës puis dès le 2 dans des moments
comme ça où est ce qu'ils ont vécu des
moments ambiguë de poser une question de
les clarifier le clarifie l'ambiguïté
pour avoir une réponse claire
c'est ce que c'est on veut son entrée tu
peux pas te tromper que la clarté une
année de la clarté fola faut la faire à
deux comme si quand on stocke je veux le
savoir 10 mois les toits gentil il
il faut mener maintenant stoxx a atteint
sa transport pour dire que quel pote
plus on a le goût de faire asseoir
ensemble ou dans le prochain 15 minutes
ou dans le projet e minute puis
impressionnant deux minutes on peut
avoir la même conversation savoir ce
qu'on est rendu dans deux minutes mais
le plaisir des hommes date avec les
femmes qu'il y ferait avec les hommes
c'est con mais notre camp
san jose c'est l'idée du couple c'est
l'idée du partenariat active moi c'est
ce que je pense je tends défenseur de la
vraie équipe plutôt que le on est rendu
à mettre le blâme sur qui en ce moment
je reçois dangereux soit même à moi je
suis d'accord avec toi quel que que oui
il faut apprendre
hauger à mieux écouter écouter mieux
mieux émettre leurs opinions pilosité
puis également faut aussi apprendre aux
hauts faits à dire à dire clairement
voici ma limite j'irai pas là et puis ça
je pense que dans l'absolu c'est ce
qu'on veut le dire clairement
celui-ci sera vendu loti rendu là je
pense pas que c'est vraiment une
question de m
c'est de mettre le blanc moelleux
discours mais ton quand je vois le
hashtag mais ne crache sur instagram
ça me donne envie de vomir à terre le
tier 2 comme de dire le problème c'est
les hommes
le problème c'est pas les hommes le
problème c'est la société dans lequel on
agrandit le problème c'est le fait que
les gosses sont pas les coûte le
problème c'est le problème est le même
que l'éducation premier problème de
communication ou est ce un problème de
communication je suis d'accord avec toi
que les deux parties dans dans l'idéal
tout le monde or sont 50% qui m'a des
quelques relations sexuelles dans ma vie
pis des risques combien nous sommes
désolés de relation même pas commencé
leur relation jusqu'à 10 mois
puis piquez les meilleures relations que
j'ai eu c'est quand la communication
était je pense que je pense qu'on est
tous d'accord avec ces cellules vraiment
si c'est faisable c'est ça s'est passé
très très faisable au t6 on apprend
certaines skies
c'est comme il ya vraiment un monde qui
s'ouvre de relations puis je pense que
dans le frais font le goût de vivre
mais oui mais oui c'est sûr qu'une
situation et mettons moi j'ai des
relations sexuelles avec quelqu'un
tout le long je dis oui ça me tente tout
est beau les yes nationale à rejeter
toute licence je m'élève puis ça me
tentait pas finalement puis n'était pas
correct cfer qu'elle est clairement et
georges et pas fait ma job de
communiquer comme du monde
ce que je voulais tpiy métier je touche
je pense pas que c'est la majorité des
connaissances qu'ils ont dans les
mouvements dénonciation des histoires
d'horreur dans les témoignages on a une
lutte épique dit m il ya des bas des
moments où est-ce que c'était clair la
communication mais ça pas été respecté
avait beaucoup sopi a dans ces moments à
l'eau je pense que c'est normal est
correct kyle blanks a porté sur
quelqu'un qui ait commis un acte était
avant même d'aller dans le crime score
quand je regrette ce qui s'est passé
c'est parce que manquer un bois qui est
passé sur juste le regret pour moi c'est
déjà beaucoup trop pourquoi phoque
qu'est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose que
vous êtes perdu de vue un moment donné
vous avez pris deux chemins différents
puis personnes cela dit c'est pour moi
le regret c'est quand même un fardeau
qui idéalement on essaye de pauvres
maison maison c'est déjà beaucoup là tu
te lèves le matin puis tu fais comme or
que c'est que j'ai faite losc-om que je
me sens mal comme ici au caire des feux
louis fait que c'est comme il ya manqué
quelque chose à quelque part même si tu
es même si steve du mauvais sexe c'est
quand on a mal communiqué dans cette
situation le
on fait tous des erreurs non mais ça
nous arrive tous puis tu es dans le fond
tu verras gré à ses come back est ce que
s'est passé et puis comment ne pas
reproduire ce sont ses sources et c'est
le goût de dire bien prochaine fois je
le fais plus de même à chaque fois je
vois je vais pas de parler de tes
lafarge peut-être pas de ralentir
d'apprendre petite pause c'est tant
mieux comme c'est dans le sexe comme des
flots si je peux dire puis l'homme
maintenant on veut pas être la personne
qui ralentissent au des fois c'est puis
on va pas être le cas sur deux de mode
mais c'est un coup sûr dans les contre
courants de de faire quelque chose que
tu veux pas vraiment faire fait que
c'est prendre le taureau par les cornes
aux normes un stop on ne la mini
conversation on a besoin d'avoir puis
cocon et corey ok on repartira vraiment
à bonne place ensemble
mais ces pauses l'eau sont super
importantes sont super importante puis
sont pas nécessairement encouragé dans
notre psyché collective
non ouais deux camps ne prennent pas de
presse que est-ce que c'est cool pour
tout le monde est ce qu on a autant de
fun toit puis - c'est rare qu'on prend
si c'est pour vous dire à excuser
jusqu'à pattes un peu ouais on dit pas
son nom maintenant un groupe peut pas
dire ce qu'il a fait je pas dû souvent
plus personne ne veut être comme gâchis
rien parce qu'on m'interdit de 12
meneurs relaxe c'est comme le proconsul
mais pour accoter la tente du moment
présent c'est énorme
souvent on parle pas assez de toi comme
concrètement le camp la relation
sexuelle qu'a rapprochement spa où cela
il y en a là des émotions là dedans
c'est super explosif
c'est pour claire quand j'ai tu dois de
stopper ce jeu est une vraie passoire
s'être jetée là c'est pas c'est vraiment
compliqué le consentement c'est pour ça
que je veux pas banaliser ce sujet la
10e' vraiment dur ça prend du courage
des deux bars avec juste le fait de
mettre une pause ailleurs
je connais un peu traîné à flamens power
s'est jusque là jusqu'à parce que le jeu
comme lui c'est repenser leur proposer
des sommets ce qu'on croit pourquoi
relaxe rien c'est bien correct
lauzon il ya personne qui quitte un kilo
jamais dit notre éducation
ça se peut que ça arrive c'est normal
c'est correct
puis quand tu as été élevé quentin
éducation s'est faite sexuelle c'est
fait mais trop sur internet
non mais quand je regarde le monde ça
l'amour y est un drame c'est que ceux ci
mais c'est ça il ya aucun moment où est
ce que je regarde mon par l'amour
qu'elle cueillait arrêté bret et le tout
sous la finale s'était amusé par exemple
disent aimer un rythme en fonction
pour moi c'est une vraie conversation
sur le consentement de toutes qu'est ce
qui peut se passer à travers de la
physicalité et puis les mots tout ça
jamais on a un cours de tous ces
problèmes
c'est quand même là c'est comme comment
tu veux savoir si t'es pas jusqu'à vous
interrompre ce n'était pas entré au
keops quelque chose de grave
je sais pour taxi site pas de gâcher
quelque chose
le consentement c'est secondaire tu veux
juste comme que ça aide un facteur qu'on
parle pas de comment ça se passe pour
vrai pour moi c'est une
c'est un concept le consentement avec
moi je n'y crois pas tant qu'on parle
pas à ce niveau-là de précisions là
puisque précision sadi graphique
par exemple un peu question je n'y crois
pas dans ce sens que pour réussir à
avoir le niveau de consentement puis de
dialogue qu'on veut dans l'instant
présent
il faut en parler de façon concrète faut
banaliser la réalité de commencer c'est
pour eux un petit mètre tu crois pas que
peut avoir un réel concernant s'il n'y a
pas une communication ultime tout ce
qu'on sait c'est comme c'est quoi la
limite du consentement josé je peux être
tout le temps plus proche puis plus
thioune sont pétris pays pollueurs
tripes et nicolas roche plus on va
assumer que le consentement et l'eau
vous êtes à même place se comprend
bon c'est ce que tu peux aller plus rare
genre ouais ouais
ces bureaux c'est mieux que non mettez
moi je pense on peut avoir même plus que
défendre que sa part tant qu'à faire on
va repousser le consentement à dire non
pas ce concept on va aller sur joint à
la même place au c'est vraiment le vrai
truc que tu veux vivre le nirvana mais
pour faire cela il faut il faut que tu
te suivre cette qui pour faire sauf deux
fautes écoute vous êtes foutus donne la
permission des affaires faut pas te
trompes landes en tête
pourquoi pourquoi le monde ont pas un
bon consentement ceux qui essaient
d'exécuter un clan idéal qui roule la
nation comme j'espère mon clan va se
rendre jusqu'à la fin si c'est ça le
problème du consentement comprend tout
ce que je veux dire il faut se parler
d'eux y'a rien de prix écrit le tout est
correct si a pas de scénario puis oublié
seul apport non piquant un bras sa part
habiter dans le mood de c'est pas comme
ça la vraie vie c'est mais plus
fluctuant que ce but pour virer cette
barbe c'est bien correct c'est ça qu'il
faut redéfinir c'est quoi par exemple
une relation sexuelle
absolument sinon c'est quoi ta marge de
manoeuvre s'est même pas dans quoi tu
t'embarques sait même pas quand le droit
de parler de telles choses
c'est un gros nathan ibant tu fais là
non ce qui se passe quelque chose c'est
comme il ya tellement de tabou que sans
briser tout c'est à boulot tu peux pour
faire un vrai consentement fait que tu
peux pour faire une vraie relation
sexuelle se repassent à travers le sexe
la séquence le critique a dit l'étude
écrite et on a reçu une coupe deux
semaines mois et rose aimée automne
démarrage que six équipes
non je m'excuse je les ai vus oui je les
ai vus dans vos pieds vous invite à la
plesse l'amant porno cède 4 tonnes sur
l'amant porno c'est comme les guêtres au
check point pi qui il déballe la
séquence que tu vois dans toutes les
vidéos laitiers wehrmacht et le le
fameux le faire le fameux quoi le fait
de la fameuse séquence par séquence qui
exhorte
genève c'est comme nous arrêtent des
dents performance pendant les
répétitions est à vue puis genre c'est
toi bien le dans quelque chose ensemble
c'est un gros problème au consentement
parce que c'est un scénario qui est sur
auld en tête des coûte rien et il le oui
te donne un oui pour ce scénario les
enfants way que tu as déjà construit oui
fake mais moi je suis moi je suis 100%
d'accord peut-être que c'est une
question de sémantique j'imagine sur la
sur la différence sur la divergence de
d'opinion mettons parce que je pense
qu'il essentiellement l'idée c'est de
construire de quoi en proximité le plus
possible avec quelqu'un puis évidemment
je pense que je pensais c'est l'auteur y
est né j'ai l'impression que oui puis je
suis d'accord petit ça ça passe
grandement par l'éducation sexuelle puis
ce sont en parle on en parle on en parle
on en parle depuis depuis plusieurs mois
le tir de dja faut revoir revoir la
façon qu'on enseigne toujours surtout
maintenant qu'on a notre cellulaire à
portée de main puis que des enfants de
12 ans ont leur celle là à portée de
main aussi mais oui c'est sorti il faut
que ce soit abordée je pense la porno à
l'école de tout ça c'est quoi là pour
nous ça c'est la sexualité la vraie vie
ça c'est de la porno qui est un
spectacle basé sur le sexe des jeux
comme qui ces deux choses c'est deux
choses
ok je sors de dixon vous ai pas besoin
de ça copier solo c'est comme ça c'est
un film c ou le débattement de titres
des films barça même chose sur ce film
mais est du sexe et des personnages
c'est tout faux c'est comme ça c'est
comme c'est un film mais c'est un tabou
autour de toi te fait quoi toi quand tu
veux bien faire c'est un tout un groupe
qui est fière de toi impressionné la
fille l'a fait vite impressionné
chacun va de son scénario ce corps à
corps on s'en sortira jamais sa
communication s'en aller droit dans des
sujets qui à quatre ports ça parle de
qu'est-ce qu'on veut vive puis ça pas
besoin d'être des tabous que je pense
dans cette aboulie ya eu tellement peur
que
ça inhibe le consentement mutuel c'est
fou comment que la porno c'est
probablement la chose la plus amis
présents dans la société dont les gens
parlent le moins mérité une grotte ça
fait partie du quotidien
une grande majorité du monde la regarde
le tire régulièrement latine qui quand
est ce qu on entend parler publiquement
humala a privé qu'on en parle c'est que
ces six mois c'est fou face à plat une
proportion d'une partie de la vie quand
même de deux majorité de personnes cessé
une partie de leur vie les yportais tant
de tort par jour par semaine consacrées
à ce oui mais on n'en parle jamais ouais
c'est quand même capoté dans les films
pornos jamais tu vois les voie rentrer
de parler ça roule la scène akrout balle
dans l'évier hilton et vie brisée ong
pour le réparer
[Rires]
non mais c'est ça je pense qu'on touche
un point super important ce qui revient
aux attentes fait que tient les humains
ça tellement peur de pas et acide
on se retrouve hautement vulnérables
tout nu avec quelqu'un c'était 6 et d'un
indice de venir habiter super fort ouais
mais tu te parle pas en dessous ça
revient ce qu'on dit de salon c'est tout
ce que du mauvais sexe pour ce concept
on regrette on est pas sûr qu est-ce que
c'est parce que tu avais rien en dessous
enfin passer de l'intimité comme ceux de
sète copier un modèle assez de faire une
image d'ascète faire un film pour te
rassurer s'est rien passé avec c'est une
communication comme un autre mais ça
reste un gros sujet c'est beaucoup
d'intimité et aide à l'intimité de
l'autre sexe est rare pont qui est assez
fort ainsi tout à fait légitime que qui
est de la communication la base assure
pour christophe pons là ça explique
grandement pourquoi des fois je préfère
juste retourner chez nous puis
m'endormir peuvent réveiller tout seul
la même attente ne pas avoir quelqu'un
mais tong sang qui repose 7
ce niveau au dessus lui cette
communication le métier en même temps je
pense que je serais d'accord de dire
quelqu'un qu'une communication vraiment
bonne et quelqu'un sait-il baisse la
best of the best factice ici mais 38,5
et paulo 4 5 et paul à 4/5 paulo mais
quand
mettons que tu re donc il dit j'aime
mieux être seul avec quelqu'un c'est
peut-être parce que tu redoutes une
mauvaise communication
j'aime mieux être sûr qu'avec quelqu'un
en inde en général et on wye sans doute
moins sur ce genre de papier et web
écouter c'est un sujet qui est qui est
fascinant et complexe
un christ piqué aussi du seul a abordé
puis que je pense que je pense qu'ils on
fait de la bonne nuance il circule pas
de casse permet quand même de nuancer
tout les points de vue je veux qu'on
parle un peu de leadership parce que je
sais que c'est quelque chose qui est à
aborder beaucoup chez post suivait un
petit peu occupation double cette année
non j'ai pas très bon mais il ya eu un
espèce de pot limit parce qu'il est un
gars qui s'appelait charlie qui
s'appelle charles d'ailleurs je n'en
traduit pas moins que le leader
autoproclamé exactement exactement
pilule c'est qui
chaque fois que l'occasion se présentait
se présentait lui même comme un leader
pour plusieurs raisons que j'ignore
vraiment sa perception de lui même
mais ce qui nous a été montrée puis je
ne rentrais pas dans es ce que c est ce
que c'est la télé ou est-ce que c'est
lui vraiment parce que je connais pas la
personne mais qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'un
leader qu'est ce qu'un réel leader parce
que j'ai vu j'ai vu les vidéos que te
fais sur le leadership qui souvent en
fait je mentionne que leader c'est
quelqu'un que tu veux vouloir suivre
sans vraiment savoir pourquoi quelqu'un
il faut mettre l'équipe en premier pic
défini mois un leader pour toi comment
est-ce que ça passe par la communication
un leader c'est quelqu'un qui est
capable d'avoir accès à de l'énergie
dans un système humain et dans l'humaine
donc un excellent job d'accès au
potentiel et 2 juillet capable de
diriger l'énergie il fait deux affaires
il est bon pour accéder y vont pour
diriger en fonction d'un objectif c'est
soit ça john cissé faire sur un haut
niveau pour moi c'est un leader
impressionnant comme il fait même plein
de façons un leader des caractéristiques
psychologiques voudrait particulière
sais où tu t'en gore une fée qui qui est
capable de vulnérabilité c'est à dire y
est capable de rêver à des affaires
qu'il touche profondément
s'il est capable de suivre l'on parle de
leadership au 1 je n'ai compris ok puis
fait c'est pas quelqu'un juste qui donne
des ordres
c'est quelqu'un qui est capable de rêver
puis il est capable de ne pas dormir
tellement qui trippent sont un facteur
qui voit son truc dans sa tête une
personne qui est que des idéaux qu'un
système de valeurs c'est quelqu'un qui
aspire à quelque chose de grand de beau
c'est quelque chose qui m
une personne qui imaginent quelque chose
puis après source d'une personne qui est
capable de transmettre cette vision là à
des humains puis de choisir le bon
langage pour que les humains face
d'entrée d'être là dedans cette
conversion l'os et des habiletés pour
moi deux leaders qui sont assez rares je
te dirais moindre erreur il beaucoup de
gestionnaires peu de leaders c'est par
là qu'ils kaki qu'est ce qu'elle est la
distinction du fait entre un
gestionnaire prix de un gestionnaire est
partie des tâches qui coordonne il rêve
pas il n'est pas capable d'accéder à de
l'énergie
il structure qui était excédé l'énergie
c'est à dire accéder à des rêves accéder
du potentiel accéder à des idées accéder
des idéaux accéder à accéder à des
standards des objectifs qui sont par
terre imaginez tout ce monde là ok tout
ce monde-là interne un leader est
capable de faire ça ainsi des grands
leaders tout sur deux niveaux de
leadership
mais les grands leaders sont capables de
se plonger dans un monde comme ça c'est
dans leurs veines
ils y ont forgé une vision en laquelle
il croit puisqu'elle est le propre des
gens mais dans quel effet ça fait sur
des sources sûres sur un bassin de
personnes qu'elle aimait tant
six coteaux un leader et ce quel que les
leurs qu'est ce que ça va te faire
souvent le goût d'être meilleur ça va te
donner la fois que quelque chose qui
vaut la peine soit sa peau de prix ça
pour les humains car un leader capable
de mettre une vision en place qui dit
qui donne le goût aux gens de se lever
le matin pour les flammes il ya
peut-être quelque chose qui vous la
peine de se forcer pour moi c'est sûr
leadership qui est plus gras leader au
monde
ils font ça se dit ça vaut la peine gala
vision guerre en participation ces
malades
un exemple de leader qui fait se
souvient il y en a beaucoup c'est sain
sans vouloir caricaturise et c'est rené
lévesque
richard ferso définitivement si je dis
c'est pas pour rien qu'on en parle
encore
c'est ce que je pense que personne dans
le temps en ce moment c'est rené
lévesque est quand même levé beaucoup de
passion puis définitivement ça
correspond à la description que fait
d'un leader on dirait qu'en ce moment il
n'y a personne qui lève la passion de la
population les mettons dans la sphère
politique fait qu'est ce que c'est juste
qu'il ya pas de leader ou est ce que
c'est juste qu'il ya une espèce
d'épuisement politique
non c'est que des leaders mais son port
sont pas aussi puissants que
dubai dalida puissant mais qu'est ce qui
fait que parfois on suit des mauvais les
deux parce que je crois en sa vision
pareil il n'y a pas de convaincre un
leader et pas nécessairement toujours
positif non s'ils n'ont pas
nécessairement et le masque c'est un
super leader
l'outil maintenant je pense que les
actions de la peau il valait je pense
169 dollars quelque chose comme ça c'est
à paul ça roule
puis il masque lui d'un trou de deux
milliards
son action vous 359 dans ce soit
difficile ça va la valeur de l'action
vient d'où juste la vision du bio
jusqu'il ya pas de convaincre le monde
que ça va quelque part tu achètes la
vision du groupe sur garde ce golf c'est
tellement clair c'est malade 1
c'est pour ça que tu payes fac les
finances vont très proche du leadership
des processus reviennent au leadership
et sa de la valeur c'est quantifiable
c'est puissant
ghislaine lorsque céline bosc c'est les
caractéristiques uniques puis escure
mettant mes tantes analyse la
communication est ce que tu es capable
d'expliquer donald trump 1 puisqu'elle
met ton site avait à analyser l'effet
d'un autre homme puis pourquoi est-ce
qu'ils autant de monde qui le suivent
plus autant de monde qui sont tellement
attachés à lui qu'est ce qu'est ce qui
explique cela sa vision est claire il
n'y a pas de doute pour lui il n'ya pas
d'anxiété et puissant c'est c'est un coq
et puissante peut pas faire une affaire
de même mièvre si je peux dire c ou
hamiton faut que ce soit en l'inpi lui
dans sa tatie en ligne ça n'existe pas
le doute qui lisent mais ont besoin de
sous ils veulent se dégage est
possiblement borloo mais a besoin d'une
direction cela redonne suivons suivent
laquelle la question c'est est ce que tu
te crées une bonne élection bonne qui
est bonne pour les
mais ça c'est une autre question notre
discussion c'est une autre discussion
puis avoir les deux c'est bien qu'obama
en fait une paupière jobs un bon leader
il était au niveau vraiment des skieuses
jeudi il fait vraiment l'autre c'est
très fort au niveau de la communication
est pas payée bon jeu pas d'accord et
toutes ces politiques tout est à falaise
d'une autre affaire l'autre des parties
ouais mais je dis comme comme
performance de leader jeudi
si j'ai pas grand monde qui bosse aulas
actuellement est ce que comme la
communication puis comme la natation ça
s'entraînent ce travail est ce qu'être
un leader ça s'apprend oui oui mais ça
dépend de ta machine ça dans ton cerveau
que ça dépend du power que tu as besoin
pour arriver sur jive rpi là ça va
prendre tout un ouais c'est sûr il faut
que ce soit hyper développé là qu'on
parle de de certains très personnelle
titiller 5 très personnel de base pour
les humains pour le leadership ça prend
une très forte extraversion puis un
train très fort conscience usitc d'une
capacité d'organisation
d'éléments abstraits capable d'avoir des
buts l'aer est capable dé très
disciplinés très précis ça c'est la
conscience usités la conscience est
conscient suscité plus l'extraversion si
les deux plus grands traits personnalité
du leader à sa version cdh est
extravertie c'est ne prévoit pas de
s'affirmer ne pas avoir pas d'aller au
devant les dialogues d'être à l'aise
avec les gens
un autre personnalité qui lui doit être
beau c'est le nouveau tisme c'est la
tendance aux émotions négatives
tu peux pas être un bon leader s'était
constamment envahie d'émotions négatives
c'est impossible d'en face à gérer tes
émotions négatives ou des émotions
négatives soit naturellement de faible
intensité
sinon ça ça le truc complètement ton
processus là on a parlé de trois enfants
juste juste pour le fun c'est quoi les
deux autres puis c'est quoi leur rôle
mais tendant veepee dans un dans ton lit
de m les deux autres qu'on compte
moyennement l'autre c'est l'ouverture
sauf qu'à passer des titis mulet par des
nouvelles idées la curiosité imagination
puis l'autre
l'ags réhabilité c'est la tendance à
vouloir s'occuper des autres diminue les
émotions négatives des autres créé des
émotions possibles chez les autres
rechercher le consensus
ce n'est pas du tout un très beau rallye
de plus une personne est très très
agréable - un leader avant être plus à
les porter à suivre finalement à suivre
la vision d'un autre que des familles la
sienne oui avoue vouloir plaire comme
mettons à ruda arroux doyen très très
forte très forte à gré habilité ce qui
fait en sorte qu'au début on l'aimait
puis après s'est fait complètement gâché
c'est le typique des leaders avec une
trop forte à gré habilité mal géré est
ce que met on compte maintenant que cet
exemple est fascinant daruda est ce que
tu crois quelqu'un avec des traits de
leadership plus aigus aurait réussi à
garder la sympathie la population plus
longtemps oui tout à fait fake
au delà d'une question de la politique
on parle vraiment d'une question de
l'être humain
oui c'est fascinant c'est d'imaginer ce
mets ton de se dire est ce que quelqu'un
avec des moeurs capacités de leader a
réussi a moins créé une division au sein
de la population
tout à fait puis mais après ça s'est
apprécié de 10 est-ce que ça devient la
mettons la valeur qui vole plus pour
pour la sphère politique parce que dans
le fond ce que tu veux si c'est unir le
plus possible au delà d'être cartésien
puis de prendre les bonnes décisions ce
que tu veux c'est d'unir le plus
possible en fait qu'un terrain quand et
politiciens pour premièrement de faire
élire deuxièmement mener une société
univers une direction
oui fait que la chose la plus près la
principale se serait selon selon ce que
tu utilises le leadership
ça prenait des bonnes habiletés de
leadership mais aussi c'est parce que
dans un contexte politique un parti
politique ou les personnes au pouvoir
sont attaqués sans arrêt c'est très
difficile c'est la job la plus dure au
monde qui ont sous-estimé toutes les
skieuses qui sont nécessaires pour faire
ça puis moi j'ai plus tendance et très
sympathique en vadrouille et les
problèmes
c'est tellement spectaculairement
difficile cet incroyable jeu puis
honnêtement je trouve françois legault y
fait une bonne job je trouve qu'il fait
il y fait des belles affaires je trouve
qu'il ya quand même des yeux des baux
très bon tir rien n'est parfait dans vie
mais moi je trouve qu'il fait plutôt une
bonne job mais
yo tout le programme aussi qui défend
les idées qu'ils défendent comme un
négocié ces choses qui ont écrit ces
alliances c est bien des choses qui sont
pas sur la sphère publique directe ça se
joue un peu dans des meetings privé la
plupart des choses facture beaucoup de
variables
c'est difficile quand on voulait toutes
les variables dans politique c'est très
difficile mais c'est surtout la
personnalité y est pour beaucoup
est ce que tu peux te trouves tu
autoproclamé leader
c'est quelque chose qui existait mais je
serai l'habitude c'est plus les gens qui
choisissent comme leader c'est pas un
titre que tu t'achètes avec un trophée
chez bull mais n'a été fait juste le
fait dire si c'est comme ces salles en
contenait du leadership c'est pas
quelque chose de tâches est là c'est pas
quelque chose que tu dis comme un
diplôme que quatorze médailles qui était
gagnée fait que le fait de dire mon cher
leader
c'est sûr ça sonne bizarre tu sais comme
trop titre dispose est occupé à faire
arriver une vision un vrai lit 2 s'est
occupée 1 les deux ça se vend pas comme
leaders les plus grands leaders au monde
vont pas se dit bonjour leader lille
je n'ai jamais tu vas entendre ça c'est
pour ceux comme des poubelles di meco
j'ai hâte de voir c'est quoi ta
démonstration de sa fac ci suit le dit
plus que ce que tu le démange te dirait
ton livre s'appelle je suis sincère
chardat pourquoi cette ses troupes
allaient d'entente au oui c'est
simplement pour le définir
oui c'est ça ben pour moi là c'est le
potentiel d'une personne c'est tout les
secrets cachés c'est toute la beauté qui
à l'inter une personne peut tout gâcher
puis les humains si incroyablement
puissants comme potentiel c'est
inimaginable
puis l'idée s'est pas créé le potentiel
c'est juste d'y avoir accès c'est là
t'as pas besoin travaillé si fort que ce
faux juste s'organiser pour accéder à ça
et on va bénéficier fait pour moi un
humain si parfait commis c'est que ce
soit un homme une femme ce soit
n'importe quelle culture
garde le potentiel est là quelque part
l'idée c'est est ce qu'on peut y avoir
accès on peut tu l'organiser ensemble si
on peut travailler ensemble sur des
objectifs communs oui c'est de ça qu'on
a besoin
avec ce beau mot lors c'est ça
représente le potentiel humain puis la
communication c'est la stratégie pour y
accéder sur le très intéressant
c'est sûr que je lire où est ce que les
gens qui nous écoutent de suivre où est
ce qu'on va juste consommer ben je quand
même je pense qu'un pas mal instagram
facebook
twitter linkedin youtube youtube
c'est ça le lait le livre est en vente
depuis depuis quelques jours est en
vente et en audio et un audio il a lu
ouais c'est moi qui les lui
tant qu'à faire la paix de revioo nous
mettons les sujets les thèmes
le contenu de ce livre le matin on fait
partie autobiographique le lien que la
natation les lois de l'univers auquel la
physique relié à la communication
apprécié aux experts des thèmes généraux
comme la conscience comment tu utilises
tu as conscience en mouvement ce que tu
en as besoin chaque instant data
communications
j'explique la notion d'énergie comment
tu utilise l'énergie comment tu peux le
voir chez une personne soit la
psychologie à dire là dedans
convaincante on est capable de le sentir
comment tu configurer bus de
communication parce que la façon dont se
configure tebbutt des sujets de
conversation c'est ce qui va être joués
avait le tort que de sa conversation
avec s'était pas les bons but puis bon
sujet serait très difficile que
j'explique comment configurer les buts
conversation j'explique tout les
systèmes attentionnel les timings de
parole explique les erreurs classiques
qua non pour faire quoi faire j'explique
les traits de personnalité tout les
traits personnalité plus style de
communication conclut se connaître un
peu plus pour connaître un peu les
patronnes de l'autre campus mieux s'y
ajuster j'explique comment formuler un
message pour que le monde écoute parce
qu'une bonne façon de places étaient des
blocs d'éléments pour créer de la
mobilisation au bout de ton propos c'est
inverse des éléments ça marche pas pij
expliqué je parle des anecdotes des
anecdotes des tribus que j'ai vécu
depuis que j'étudierais communication
pour mieux me sortir du pétrin dans ce
faire un pays enfin que j'explique tout
ce techniquement comment je les applique
et qui combattent à appliquer ce qui est
exprimé plus tôt dans le livre est dans
une situation où hospital est allé
mourir saison le fait d'aller à la
rencontre mettant deux tribus lol ouais
est ce que ça a changé
est-ce que ça confirme une hausse à
changer certaines notions que tu pensé
ok tu que tu croyais la communication ça
le dessus c'était de saintes et de sable
niveau encore nous a confirmé des choses
j'ai coup il a confirmé que ce comme
toutes les catégories sociales
on s'en fout on devrait pas on devrait
pas accroché là dessus c'est nos
différences le oui on a des différences
individuelles
ok c'est correct
mais ce qui détermine le nerf de la
guerre c'est des mécanismes communs
indépendamment nos différences d'une aux
classes sociales puis nos étiquettes
qu'on se met toutes ses affaires le qui
nous divise
on n'a pas besoin d'être soi puis moi
j'ai écrit ce livre le plus autant j'ai
fait le show tribales parce que je
voulais juste montrer qu'elle regarde
moi c'est une minorité jeux différents
deux autres himat en dépôt ils veulent
pas me voir la face et pourtant il n'a
pas de racisme pourtant son compte en ne
le voit on et kata décrit une relation
on parle même pas la même langue mais on
n'a rien en commun puis pourtant on est
bien heureux de temps et ensemble on est
content de faire des activités ensemble
pour moi c'est son ex tête l'humanité
que j'ai le goût d'année c'est les
catégories sociales il faut pas
accrocher sur la fopac rocher là dessus
vous accrocher sur les affaires qu'on
ait de commun alors début comme un puits
dans god les cerveaux ces faits pour
s'entendre
ce sera un moment sa veine l'espèce de
dimension universelle à la communication
dans ce sens qui on partage aucun codes
sociaux comment avec ses dribbles ou
presque le sait vraiment besoin
complètement en retrait de la
civilisation que nous on connaît pour
nous tous revenus 1 qui malgré ce n'est
capable de créer un lien ça montre que
lise main à la base dans sa nature même
il ya vraiment des choses qui les unit
oui oui moi c'est ça mon message qu'il
faut vraiment faut vraiment pour faut
résister à l'idée de rester un petit peu
dans un an dans notre propre catégorie
pour créer de l'opposition pis c'est pas
le futur sur le futur c'est pas là dans
la division se dire comment on peut être
plus proches comment on peut échanger
des affaires puis comment on peut
travailler en équipe pour un mois que ça
soit en pays groupe que ce soit en
couple c'est juste une question d'
équipe il faut absolument travers une
équipe ça se fait le second par seconde
conversation par conversation petits
gestes partie geste c'est comme ce petit
cru que tu crées des relations que tu
tricote des relations puis moi je crois
beaucoup je suis très proche human pro
humain qui
pour moi le chercheur dans c'est que
tout le monde leur piquant c'est de
l'art ces deux là quand ça bouge ça vaut
cher la fouille accéder un premier pion
fait pas qu'est ce qu'on est ensemble
puis à plein d'affaires à faire ensemble
de super positive mais c'est super
intéressant puis on invite tout le monde
qu'ils écoutent et cela allait creuser
plus en italie où ça fait mal
merci beaucoup pour la belle diction
mais maintenant ça ça peut pas être
symbolique